wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you two
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some of the
best mel
robbins motivation of all time enjoy
we bought into this this complete
falsehood
that at some point you're going to have
the courage at some point you're going
to have the confidence and it's total
frankly are we allowed to swear okay um
it's it's complete garbage and so there
are so many people
in the world and and you know you may be
watching this right now
and you have these incredible ideas and
what you think is missing is motivation
and that's not true because the way that
our minds are wired
and the fact about human beings is that
we are not
designed to do things that are
uncomfortable
or scary or difficult our brains are
designed
to protect us from those things because
our brains are trying to keep us alive
and in order to change in order to build
a business in order to be the best
parent the best spouse to do all those
things that you know you want to do with
your life with your work with your
dreams you're going to have to do things
that are difficult uncertain or scary
which sets up this problem for all of us
you're never going to feel like it
motivation's garbage you only feel
motivated
to do the things that are easy right
why do you think that is oh i know
exactly why that is
because i i've studied this so much
because for me one of the hardest things
to figure out
was why is it so hard
to do the little things that would
improve my life
and what i've come to realize and what
we'll talk a lot about today
is that the way that our minds are
designed
is our minds are designed to stop you
at all costs from doing anything
that might hurt you and the way that
that that
that this all happens is it all starts
with something super subtle
that none of us ever catch and that is
with this habit that all of us have that
nobody's talking about
we all have a habit of hesitating
we have an idea you're sitting in a
meeting you have this
incredible idea and instead of just you
know
saying it you stop and you hesitate now
what none of us realize is that when you
hesitate just that moment that micro
moment
that small hesitation it sends a stress
signal to
your brain it wakes your brain up and
your brain all of a sudden goes oh
wait a minute wait why is he hesitating
he didn't hesitate when he put on his
killer
spiky sneakers he didn't hesitate with
the uh really cool track pants he didn't
hesitate with the nasa t-shirt
now he's hesitating to talk something
must be up so then your brain goes to
work to protect you
it has a million different ways to
protect you one of them is called the
spotlight effect it's a
known phenomenon where your brain
magnifies risk why
to pull you away from something that it
perceives to be a problem
and so you can truly
trace every single problem or complaint
in your life
to silence and hesitation those are
decisions
and what i do and what's changed my life
is waking up and realizing that
motivation's garbage i'm never going to
feel
like doing the things that are tough for
difficult or uncertain or scary or new
so i need to stop waiting
until i feel like it and number two i am
one decision away
from a totally different marriage a
totally different life
a totally different job a totally
different income a totally different
uh relationship with my kids not like
one decision
i'm divorcing you in in the marriage
example but one decision
on you know you could be having a
conversation with your spouse and you
feel your emotions rise up
and within a tiny window those emotions
can take over and can impact how your
marriage goes
or you can learn how to take control
of that micro moment and make a decision
to act in a way that actually shifts
your marriage your life
comes down to your decisions and if you
change your decisions
you will change everything when i was 22
right after i graduated from dartmouth i
was so
focused on making everyone happy that i
almost chose
the worst possible career for my
personality it's not a bad career it
just would have been horrendous for me
i was interested in the environment so i
decided oh you know i'll go get a law
degree
and then i'll go work in washington and
i think maybe i'll work on environmental
policy and i'd probably end up in some
cube farm and everyone was thrilled with
the plan
everyone it turns out but me so here i
am i'm driving a u-haul across country
to go to law school and to get a degree
in environmental law
and something started to gnaw at me
and with every single mile that i drove
my thoughts were getting louder and
doubts were starting to pour in
my gut was telling me mel turn the damn
u-haul around
but the problem was that everything was
already in place right i mean i'm
already in the u-haul
the thing is already packed i'm already
10 miles into my drive
the tuition had been paid for the first
semester i had signed a lease
i mean i could not undo these things
isn't that why it's so difficult for you
to make changes in your life
because you think that things can't be
undone
the fact is any excuse that you come up
with you can undo
tuition can be reimbursed apartments can
be leased
plan b can be invented so i got up i
repacked that u-haul and i drove out of
town i let myself
make a u-turn in life if you ever find
your gut
battling your head save yourself the
drama i guarantee you your gut is right
guarantee you your excuses can be undone
and i guarantee
you you can make a u-turn in your life
right now
if you want to one night chris had gone
to bed
i had been struggling struggling
struggling we still had all the same
problems
i we stole a lien on the house still
facing bankruptcy still fighting like
crazy i was still unemployed
he still they still hadn't figured out
like the solution yet for the business
and i was about to turn off the tv and
there on the
tv there was this rocket launching and i
thought oh my gosh
that is it
i am going to launch myself out of bed
like a rocket ship like nasa right here
had launched me out of that bed and i'm
gonna move so fast
that i don't think i'm gonna beat my
brain
now here's a really interesting point um
i talk a lot about your instincts and
inner wisdom
and we can get into this a little bit
later but a lot of us talk about the
fact that you have a gut feeling but
what all this research that i've done
for the book and and all the speaking
that i do what i've discovered that's
fascinating is actually
when you set goals when you have an
intention on something that you want to
change about your life
your brain helps you what it does is it
opens up a checklist
and then your brain goes to work trying
to remind you
yeah of that intention that you set and
it's
really important to develop the skill
and i say that word purposefully the
skill
of knowing how to hear that inner wisdom
and that intention kicking in
and leaning into it quickly so for me my
brain saying that's it
right there move as fast as a rocket
mill
i wanted to change my life and i think
most people that are miserable
or that are that are really like dying
to
be great and dying to have more we want
to change we want to
live a better life we want to create
more for our families we want to be
happier
the the desire is there again it's about
how do you go from knowledge to action
so the first thing in this story that's
important is realizing that the answer
was in me
and my mind was telling me pay attention
it could have also been the bourbon
manhattan's that night
anyway the next morning the alarm goes
off and
um i pretended nasa was there
it's the stupidest story i literally
went five four three
two one i counted out loud and then i
stood up
and i i'll never forget standing there
in my bedroom it was
dark it was cold it was winter in boston
and for the first time in three months i
had beaten my habit
of hitting the snooze button i couldn't
believe it
and i thought wait a minute counting
backwards that is the
dumbest thing i've ever heard in my
entire life well the next morning i used
it again and it worked
the next morning i used it again and it
worked the next morning i used it again
and it worked
and then i started to notice something
really interesting
there were moments all day long all
day long just like that five second
moment
in bed where i knew
knowledge what i should do
and if i didn't move within five seconds
my brain would step in and talk me out
of it
every human being has a five second
window might even be shorter
for you you have about a five second
window in which
you can move from idea to action before
your brain kicks into full gear
and sabotages any change in behavior
because remember your brain is wired to
stop you from doing things that are
uncomfortable or uncertain or scary
it's your job to learn how to move from
those ideas that could change everything
into acting on also if you want to have
unstoppable confident self-love and
learn from successful women
entrepreneurs check out my 254 series
they're free
the links to join are in the description
below i know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see
i first had to learn how to have the
courage to speak up and have hard
conversations in my life
in order to get to the next level in
your business you got to decide right
now
what habits do you have as a leader
that you have to change now i think you
have to
be really in tune with your impulses
and with your natural state of curiosity
and your curiosity and the things that
you're naturally drawn toward
that's the guide if you could spend
hours singing if you could spend hours
baking if you could spend
hours writing if you could spend hours
learning code
that's a huge signal that that's
something that you're really
innately interested in and so if you're
curious about something if you notice
that you daydream about being a writer
if you notice that you daydream about
starting a tech company if you notice
you daydream about building bridges
follow your curiosity and you can do
that a number of ways
first of all google it there are
millions and millions of
pages out there on the web that are
related to what you're interested in
secondly find an online course most of
the major universities are offering
their courses online for free
third buy a book about it put yourself
in a collision course with the thing
that you're curious about
and you will get closer and closer and
closer to figuring it out
what about when someone can't realize or
identify
their own negative feelings someone that
has been conditioned to live in negative
feelings and believes that that's normal
this question comes from baso anna
dinagada
um it is your normal you're right it's a
really
um first of all i'm sorry that that's
been your experience of life because
that
really stinks and it doesn't have to be
that way but
here here's where i want you to go
what's interesting about what you said
is
the fact that these feelings are normal
okay normal just means you're used to
them
but you don't have to live with them so
even though you're so used to these
negative feelings and these feelings of
doubt
you still don't like them you still have
the ability to stop that
so i want you to think of a moment in
time when you were really happy
like it could be a memory from being
little it could be something that you
dream of doing and i want you to come up
with something really specific
about that moment okay like think about
what you're wearing or think about the
the the blue sky
that is going to be what i call your
anchor thought
every time from this moment forward that
you wake up or you find yourself
drifting to those normal feelings of i'm
a loser
i'm worthless i'm never gonna find love
they may be things that you're used to
thinking
but that doesn't that doesn't matter
because you can change them
the second that you feel that
you've drifted over into that thought
and i keep coming over here because when
you start using the rule you're going to
start to
literally feel which part of your mind
you're using the worries kind of happen
here
i want you to five four three two one
and then i want you to insert
this vision of yourself this vision of
yourself where you felt
really good and if you can't think of
one
invent one how would you feel if you
were in love how would you feel if you
loved yourself how would you feel if you
did that thing that you're scared of
that you keep talking yourself out of
that's your anchor thought now when you
first start using the rule
particularly when you're breaking a
habit
a habit of thinking negative thoughts
when you
first start doing it you may need to use
the five second rule 73 times
in one day that's okay i had to do it
like that when i was first using the
rule to cure myself of anxiety
when i would start to worry about
anything i'd start to worry about you
know my kids or i'd start to worry about
money and i'd feel my thoughts drift and
then i'd start to feel my heart race i
would stabilize my thoughts five four
three two one i've activate my
prefrontal cortex lower the
the worries you know on the other side
and then i would start to think
about something that actually made me
feel really calm or excited
that is the battle of your mind and you
know the other thing about normal that i
just want to say is that the reason why
it feels normal to doubt yourself
and to have low self-worth is because
you've thought this so long
it's become a pattern just like chewing
your nails becomes a pattern of behavior
that you don't think about
well the cool thing is is that based on
science you can
actually change any pattern even a
thinking one
so use the five second rule every single
time you catch yourself
thinking the nasty stuff and then
activate your prefrontal cortex
and force yourself to think something
positive
every single morning monday through
fridays at 9 00 am
i host a live call-in radio show on
sirius satellite radio
it's called make it happen with mel
robbins and the thing that's been
so crazy about that show is every single
person that calls me on that show they
call in
because they're feeling stuck in their
lives
and they're resigned about their ability
to change their lives and i'm not
talking about people that are nuts
i'm talking about successful people like
you and me
that just somehow got stuck in their
lives and i'm not talking about people
that are looking for cheesy self-help
i'm talking about people that really
want to figure out how to move
themselves forward
and you know i find that so many of us
think that our dreams are unreachable or
unrealistic
and it's just so sad i mean people think
that their dreams disappear
and if that's what you think
congratulations
you're officially stuck and the truth is
that our dreams are always there and
they don't ever give up on us
we give up on them but here's the secret
if you just force yourself and i mean
force because i know damn well none of
you want to do anything about this
and i also know you're sitting there
like yeah the self-help crap this isn't
for me
but if you just force yourself to take a
couple small steps
there's always a surprise so let's talk
about starbucks
starbucks in 2008 um
very interesting thing happened and many
of you if you were in the financial
services market then probably know this
that their net income decreased by about
28
that year and at the time they had
16 000 stores in 44 countries and they
had gone through this
massive explosive growth segment in
terms of going from going public in
i think it was like 1992 they only had
125 stores and now here we are 2008
they've got 16
000. so what ends up happening is howard
schultz who is the chairman of the board
comes back in as the ceo
very complex situation right you've got
operations in 44 countries you've got
massive reduction in terms of the
profits that you have
you've got the stock market and wall
street screaming at you you've got
customers that are going to dunkin
donuts because there's a recession
that's hitting so what do you do
well he was very clear again back to the
two
rules what do i stand for like what is
it
what is what am i doing and what do i
want the outcome to be
so he was very clear that what he stood
for as a leader and what starbucks
should stand for
is the starbucks experience he wanted to
go back to the beginning
and reintroduce people to the romance of
having a cup of coffee because you know
that's how
starbucks launched in the beginning that
he was traveling and was over in italy
and was like god why don't we have
places like these great
stops to have a little cup of coffee
over in the united states boom
starbuck's an idea it's born it's
launched
so he decides he's going to do whatever
he can to get the romance of having a
cup of coffee
back in life in any situation
whether you're talking about growing
your company growing your bank account
getting in a relationship getting out of
a relationship getting
something done at the school system that
your kids are going to on behalf of your
kids whatever it is that you're up to in
life
this is the only question that you need
to ask yourself what is it that i want
because the truth of the matter is if
you can answer that
you can have it if it were easy to get
what you wanted in life
google would have already figured out an
app you would just type in
okay i'm a student and i want to go from
being a student to being successful and
google would tell you go to college
then you get your masters then you land
this killer job
and then you put in a bunch of face time
while you're checking facebook
then you get promoted to manager and
then you realize managing people kind of
stinks and then you keep climbing the
corporate ladder
and then you start to wonder well how
did i end up here and then you went
is this what success looks like you're
like no i'm going to go to jay hilburn
that's what success looks like
so keep this in mind if there's
something that you want like
seven people or a trip to africa or
you're going to make it to mexico in the
pink shirt i'm looking at you again sir
i'm watching you um and rooting for you
uh keep in mind this here you are
this is what you want i spend a lot of
time on lacrosse fields
although they don't really look like
this
you tend to think that what you want you
just march right towards it
but if in sports you march right towards
the goal
what happens the defenders come in and
what the defenders are is it's your
brain saying
ain't gonna happen so the second you
start moving toward that thing you want
be ready you're gonna tell yourself you
don't feel like it you're going to have
to force yourself it's happening
there's no way to get around it so what
you're going to have to do is
you're going to basically get bounced
around a lot
all over the place and there are going
to be a lot of times that you feel like
this was a really dumb idea to start
this business because it's going to get
hard
and i want to remind you about something
unlike
a sports field where there's an in and
out of bounds
the great thing about life is there
actually aren't any and it's usually in
those moments where you feel
like you can't do it that you're closer
than ever
to having everything that you wanted and
i wanted to show you this so that you
keep it in mind because i think a lot of
times when you look back
it's the darkest moments where you
realize holy cow that's what projected
me forward
we live in the most amazing moment in
time
so that thing that you have up here
whatever it may be
you want to use healthy eating to cure
your diabetes
you want to figure out how to take care
of
the elders and start a new hospice
center you want to move to africa and
build a school
guess what you could walk into a
bookstore right now
and buy at least 10 books written by
credentialed experts on how you do it
you could google it and you could
probably find at least i don't know
a thousand blogs documenting the
step-by-step by step
transformation that somebody else is
already doing
you can find anybody online and cyber
stalk them
you can just walk in their footsteps and
let that you know just use the science
of drafting
follow what everyone else has done
because somebody else is already doing
it
so why don't you have what you want
when you have all the information that
you need you have the contacts that you
need
there are probably free tools online
that allow you to start a business or
join a group or do whatever the heck you
want
it all comes down to one word
shut the front door you know what i'm
talking about
the f-bomb it's everywhere
you hear it all the time and i honestly
don't understand what the appeal is of
the word
i mean you don't sound smart when you
say it
and it's really not expressing how you
really feel
it's sort of a cheap you know shot to
take
and of course you know i'm talking about
the word
fine how you doing i'm fine
oh really you are dragging around those
extra 40 pounds you're fine
feeling like roommates with your spouse
and you're fine
you haven't had sex in four months
you're fine
really i don't think so
but see here's the deal with saying that
you're fine
it's actually genius because if you're
fine
you don't have to do anything about it
but when you think about this word fine
it just
makes me so angry i mean here we are at
a conference about being alive and
you're going to describe
the experience of being alive as fine
what a flimsy and feeble word
if you're crappy say you're crappy if
you're amazing say you're amazing
tell the truth and this not only goes
for the social construct oh i don't want
to burden you with the fact that i hate
my life or you know hey i'm amazing but
that would make you feel terrible
the bigger issue the bigger issue with
fine
is that you say it to yourself
that thing that you want i guarantee you
you've convinced yourself that you're
fine
not having it
that's why you're not pushing yourself
it's the areas in your life
where you've given up where you've said
oh i'm fine
my mom's never gonna change so i just
can't have that conversation
i'm fine you know we gotta wait until
the kids graduate before we get divorced
so
we'll just sleep in separate bedrooms
i'm fine
i lost my job i can barely pay my bills
but
whatever it's hard to get a job
and you know one of the reasons why this
word also
just annoys me so much
is scientists have calculated
oh yeah i'm coming down scientists have
calculated
the odds of you
being born that's right
they've crunched the numbers i see you
up there
they've crunched the numbers on you yeah
i know you guys standing up you want to
sit down for this
they've crunched the numbers on you
being born
and they took into account all
of the wars and the natural disasters
and the
dinosaurs and everything else
and do you realize that the odds
the odds of you yeah right here put your
computer away stand up for me
doug
so the odds of doug here turn around say
hi to everybody
the odds yeah of doug doug being born
at the moment in time he was born to
the parents you were born to with the
dna structure that you have
a hundred or one and 400 trillion
isn't that amazing i'm so lucky yes
you're not fine you're fantastic you
have
life-changing ideas for a reason and
it's not to torture yourself
thank you thank you doug
you know christine was right when she
said all of you could be on stage
because all of you we're all in this
category one
and four hundred trillion
all day long you have ideas that could
change your life
that could change the world that could
change the way that you feel
and what do you do with them nothing
hopefully i won't moon you
you didn't pay for that drive that's
this puppy right here this is what you
want this is your prefrontal cortex
drive is the mode where you're in charge
of your thoughts
okay it's where you are fully awake
you are present and you are driving your
thoughts and actions
when you're doing that your prefrontal
cortex
is active the prefrontal cortex is the
part of the brain that you need
in order to learn new behavior in order
to do something difficult
in order to do something uncertain in
order to do strategic thinking
so i'm going to give you an example so
i'm a righty if i were to try to write
with my left hand like
louis is going to torture me and tie my
hand behind my back and make me like do
this i could do it
it would look like i was riding with my
foot and if lewis came
up to me and said hey mel you want some
bulletproof coffee i'd be like louis
i'm trying to concentrate i can't do
this my prefrontal cortex would be
el fuego because it is firing on all
cylinders to communicate to my hand
new behavior so the thing that's cool
about
that is that you can use a simple trick
the moment you feel yourself hesitate
the moment you've got one of those
moments where you know that you need to
this is that moment that lewis talks to
you about where you got to step outside
of your comfort zone and you've got to
lean into your passion and you've got to
really take some risks and you've got to
feel the fear and you've got to do it
anyway
that's the moment where you just woke up
and now you got a decision to make
are you going to drift back into the
habits are you going to
awaken your prefrontal cortex and drive
forward and focus and do something new
get up 30 minutes earlier than you
normally do and push yourself to work on
the most important priorities first
this isn't just me research shows that
your most productive hours are the first
two to three
hours after you wake up and get ready
this means that for peak productivity
you've got to do whatever you can do to
make sure the most important work to you
gets done first during that window of
time
if you're living in the past you're
going to be depressed because
you are rehashing things that happen to
you that are not going to happen again
if you're living in the future you're
going to be anxious because you are
anticipating what's coming or you're
wishing for things that aren't happening
yet
being in the present is where the gold
is being in the present
moment is where you will have the
greatest control
where you will feel the most at ease and
where
happiness flourishes there's a super
tight connection between happiness and
the ability to live in the present
moment
a lot of people believe that happiness
is tied to the things that happen to you
not so at all in fact there is a
professor of positive psychology he's
one of the grandfathers of
the movement he teaches at the
university of pennsylvania his name is
martin segelman and he's studied
happiness for decades
now one of the things that we've talked
about a lot is that forty percent of
your happiness levels are preset by
genetics
60 you are in complete control of
and one of the things that this
professor has has discovered is that it
doesn't matter what's happened to you in
fact some of the people
that have had the worst things the worst
things happen to them like people that
have survived the holocaust
are actually the happiest and most
grateful people in the world
happiness comes down to this right up
here
comes down to your thoughts comes down
to your mindset it comes down to your
attitude
and you are 100 control
of what you're thinking you may not be
in control of how you feel in the moment
but you can
always always always always be in
control of what you think
and that will change how you're feeling
one of the most powerful things that you
can do in terms of think and this gets
back to strict's question is how do you
be present
being present is literally nothing more
than the skill
of having your thoughts be in this
moment not in the past
not in the future but right here the way
that you teach yourself how to do that
is that the moment that you catch
yourself
being distracted the moment you catch
yourself starting to worry
the moment you catch yourself drifting
to the future drifting to the past
that's a moment of tremendous power
because you basically just woke up
you basically just noticed that you're
not here in this particular moment
so use that wake-up call 54321 and
ground yourself in this moment
the best way to ground yourself in the
moment is to look for something
in this particular moment that you can
savor i'm using the word saver
on purpose because it's the word that
psychologists use to describe
what happens when you find something in
this moment right now
right here right now to focus on and to
appreciate
it could be literally the questions
these are these are printed out
questions from people on social media
and if i were to stop and look at these
and savor them
what i would feel in this moment is a
tremendous amount of gratitude because
people are taking the time to write
and that makes me feel incredibly
grateful and it also makes me very happy
because it means that
that the folks that are writing are
taking control of their lives and
seeking out the information that they
need
another form of savoring that we can all
relate to is eating
as you're eating instead of drifting to
the future and thinking about all the
things that you need to do or hanging
out in the past and rehashing everything
that's happened during the day
be in this moment in this meal slow down
think about the food that you're eating
think about the people that you're
sitting with
and how you feel about them and if you
want to take it up a notch
actually acknowledge them hey this food
tastes amazing thank you for cooking or
i'm so glad to see you and that we get
the time to have this meal together
those small simple acts of savoring are
how you
expand your happiness inside the present
moment
so how do you be more present simple
the moment that you catch yourself in
the future in the past worrying whatever
refocus yourself right here right now
and then find something
right here right now that you can savor
and when you do that you're not only
going to be present you're going to feel
more grateful
and you're going to feel a little boost
of happiness i want you to start seeing
something bigger i know you're all
successful i'm
talking about something really big for
your life
and in order to do that you have to
answer this question
what do you really want now i'm not
talking about something small
i'm not talking about a little haiku not
talking about renovating your kitchen
i'm not talking about signing on 10 new
customers this month
i'm talking about what you really want
know three years ago i was a lawyer and
a business coach
working with private clients and big
corporations all over the country
and i came to a seminar just like this
one
a big leadership seminar and i went
there with my husband we're both
business owners and i went because i
wanted to be
more successful and i went because i
wanted to make
even more money than i already did and i
was sitting exactly where you go
are in fact i was sitting about i don't
know 15 rows back right where that woman
with her hand on her hand like yet you
yeah she's like hi um was sitting and i
was taking notes and i'm like okay i'm
here to make more money
and then all of a sudden she walked on
stage
that is martha beck
she writes a column for oprah winfrey
she travels around
the country speaking she's a
best-selling author
and when she walked on stage i literally
stopped listening please keep listening
to me
right now and it hit me
i said i want to be doing that
i'm ready for a bigger state like that's
it
and what's so interesting about when you
answer that question
is that you don't answer it up here you
answer it here
that's how you see something bigger for
yourself you know you guys are really
cute because everybody's like i don't
see it what do you i don't see anything
for myself right now
and now i'm just confused i thought i
knew what i wanted
you know and now mel i'm not really sure
and right now the economy is so bad
i mean it's so bad that even if you're
successful
i know sometimes i feel embarrassed
talking about my success around some of
my friends because i know that they're
really struggling
and i get calls every day into the radio
show
people saying oh i've got this great
idea
but i just don't know if it's the right
time
and you know what i say to them i say
yeah you know you're right
the recession it's huge you should wait
those dreams yeah put them on hold
that's right you you should you should
stay in that job you can't stand just a
little bit longer you get college bills
to pay
i mean you know what you're doing it's
fine you're busy right
that guy you're dating he's good enough
for you but for the people
in this room baloney
you know that's right you know exactly
what you want and the only thing that
you need to do
is to admit it now this may sound weird
because i know most of you came in here
because you're like i know what i want
i'm here at success i try to figure it
out
i'm talking about something bigger
much bigger
i'll admit to you what it is that i'm up
to
and the truth is it's embarrassing
because when you lock on to something
way bigger than where you're at it is
downright
embarrassing to tell people because
you're not there yet
but i mean at this rate i've already
admitted you that i stalked martha beck
and that i brought a haiku to the best
you know lit agent in the country so i
got nothing to lose at this point
so this is what i want
well not him i'm married i want what
he's got
i want 600 radio stations
i want 2 million listeners and i could
certainly deal with the 400 million
dollar salary in fact if i got it i'd
renovate everybody's kitchen
and you know the the thing is though
that's so interesting about this
is that i didn't pick him i mean i
i'm not looking to become a cigar
smoking conservative political guy that
like stirs the pot
makes everybody all mad i'm the liberal
lifestyle gal that's trying to help
people out
but what i want to do is i want to use
radio
to entertain people and help them
achieve their dreams
and when i really think about it he's
the one that's in the front
i want to not only reach what he's doing
i want to surpass him
i mean do you think i like it when my
friends come over to my office
in boston at my house and they're like
what is that guy doing on your board
no it's embarrassing when you admit the
big
thing that you're up to it's
embarrassing i have 40 stations he's got
600
there's a big gap so admitting where you
want to get to
is embarrassing but you got to do it
mel robbins your media radio show make
it happen helps people go for success
you actually say
there are three red flags we should look
for that will actually tell us
it's time to change big ones whenever
you start feeling in your life like
oh my gosh is this all there is
huge red flag number one number two when
you spend your energy being jealous or
having the grasses greener over there
another big wake-up call for you that
you're ready for a change and then the
other
final red flag is if you're spending
your life waiting to be happy
i'll be happy when i'll be happy when i
get married i'll be happy when i change
my job i'll be happy when i watch a
business
it's time to change now because that
moment's not coming
unless you make it come but how do i
know that i'm maybe just not living
in a fantasy land that i'm never gonna
no matter where i am the grass has
always greener concept that i'll always
say this could be better and then i
might be making change for change's sake
but it might not be really what i need
baloney if you're still saying that to
yourself over and over and over again
and you're complaining
it's what you're really good at is
ignoring your gut and so it's time to
start
tuning into your gut and making some
changes okay so if people see these
signs why don't they make changes then i
mean what you just described is very
depressed
i can tell you why the reason why they
don't make changes is because what
happens is you say okay i want to do x
and then immediately what you see next
are all the obstacles
and so you're actually smart you're not
necessarily afraid you're smart because
you think how
am i going to go from being a lawyer to
a carpenter
when i have a mortgage to pay i've got
tuition bills to go my wife is going to
kill me if i make this kind of change
and so you get stuck because you see
obstacles and then you never do anything
those are very real obstacles okay so
how do i kind of get past those
obstacles very easy let's say i
recognize the warning signals
okay time for change danger oil robinson
this is not the right path
but it does seem herculean the hurdles
have to go on first don't quit your job
that's number one
second thing is i think most change in
life is not about
putting on a big cape and jumping off a
cliff or out of an airplane
it's more like leaning into something so
if you find yourself daydreaming about
something or
wishing that you could change your life
start investigating
start having conversations about it
start leaning into change right
you know i've heard a lot of experts say
that fear isn't real that is
such a bunch of baloney fear is
so real in fact there are probably
things that you're afraid of doing
right now in your life in your
relationships at work
and the fact that you're afraid that's
robbing you
of all of the experiences that you want
to have in your life i mean if you're
afraid to fly
that's going to limit your ability to
travel and see the world or go visit
friends
if you're afraid of public speaking
that's going to
really limit your ability to express
yourself and share your ideas if
you're afraid of talking to your boss or
asking for a raise
that directly impacts how much money you
make or what if you
are dreaming of starting a business or
you've already started a new business
but you're afraid to talk to people
and you're afraid to share your business
with people i mean
fear is something that stops us all
and that's why i'm here to talk to you
because it doesn't
have to fear is real but i am going to
share
a secret weapon that i have used
for years to beat every single fear
that used to stop me now first before we
get into this secret weapon
i just want to cover a few facts about
fear what it is what it isn't
and some things that you may not know
about fear
so first thing fear is a
physical state in your body that is
exactly
the same as excitement let me say that
again
fear and excitement are the exact
same physical state your heart races you
might sweat a little bit
you might feel tightening in your chest
you might feel a pit in your stomach
you have a surge of cortisol it's
basically the way that your body
goes into a hyper aware state because
it's readying for action
now what's the difference between fear
and excitement
really simple the only difference
between fear and excitement
is what your brain is doing as your body
is all agitated
if you're excited your brain's going oh
wow
this is going to be so cool to ride this
roller coaster
if you're afraid your brain's going
oh no way there's no way i'm doing that
this is dangerous get out of there
don't do that it's saying something
different
so what's critical about understanding
this is that we're going to use
the fact that your mind is either
working for you for excitement
or against you with fear to your
advantage i'll tell you about it in just
a minute how you're going to do that
second thing i want you to understand is
that you may have
heard the advice feel the fear and do it
anyway
you may have heard the advice oh just
try to calm down
think positive thoughts it doesn't work
does it and there's a reason why it
doesn't work so let's go back to fact
number one
when you're afraid your body's in a
state of arousal and agitation and your
heart is racing and you're all like
amped up
and you're hyper aware of what's going
on and you're freaking out a little bit
what is it like when you're calm ah
you just kind of chill right you got
like this low
arousal state very very difficult to go
from a state of agitation and being all
jacked up
and excited and weirded out to a
kind of state it doesn't work it's like
trying to stop a train
by throwing a boulder on the tracks it's
going to make the train jump off the
tracks it's going to cause a disaster
in fact they've proven in research that
when you try to ignore your fears it
actually makes them worse
they've also proven in research that
positive thinking alone
also can make your fears work worse so
what do you do what do you do when
you're about to go talk to your boss and
you feel afraid
what do you do when you have to get on a
plane and you're actually terrified of
flying
what do you do if you got to give a
presentation and you are afraid of
public speaking
here's what you're going to do you're
going to use a strategy the same one
that i use
that has helped me beat every single
fear and turned me into somebody
that is terrific when it comes to a high
stress
situation this is how you do it you're
going to use my five second rule
in combination with what i call an
anchor thought
and that is going to reframe what your
mind is doing so that your mind goes
from
feeling agitation and making you afraid
to reframing it from agitation to
excitement
it works like magic now i have used this
technique
for years literally for years and
one of the ways that i want to introduce
you to it is i want to take you
backstage
i want to take you backstage to a speech
that i delivered this year
and what you're going to see is you're
going to see me behind
you know the major set i'm about to walk
out you can kind of hear the crowd
roaring my introductory video is playing
my body is in a state of arousal i am
literally my heart is racing my arms are
sweating like it's like you're going to
see this i'm going to tell you about it
and you're going to watch me use this
same technique
i'm going to teach you to reframe my
nerves
into excitement check this out all right
i'm about to go on stage there are 7 000
people out there and it's so exciting
because
what they don't know is they're about to
learn the five-second rule
and their lives will never be the same
again now
i gotta tell you my heart is racing um
my armpits are sweating
i have the exact same physiological
feeling as when i'm afraid but i'm not
afraid
i'm excited excitement and fear
is the exact same thing in your body
it's just what your brain
calls it here's a trick that's proven by
science that i use
every time i speak when i start to sweat
when i start
to have butterflies when i start to have
my heart race
i say i'm excited i'm excited to get out
there
i'm excited to talk to these people i'm
excited to share the five second rule
and what that does is it sends a message
to my brain
that tells my brain why my body's all
agitated and excited and that way
i don't feel afraid remember excitement
and fear
exact same thing in your body the only
difference
is what your brain calls that's why you
want those
go get them now i want to give you one
more example
just to make sure that you really get
how you can use this
so a lot of you have written to me about
your fear of flying
and i can really relate to that fear
because i used to have the exact
same fear but i use this same strategy
to conquer it here's how you're going to
do it
so first things first if you've got to
do something that really makes you
nervous or that you're afraid
to do before you're about to do it come
up with an anchor thought
what's an anchor thought well an anchor
thought is something that's going to
anchor you so that you don't
escalate any situation into a full-blown
panic attack or into a situation where
you screw things up
it's a way for you to anchor yourself so
you maintain control
over what you're thinking and how you
behave so here's an example with flying
it's important when you're creating an
anchor thought to
pick something that is in the proper
context
of what you're afraid to do so for
flying
pick an anchor thought that has to do
with the trip that you're taking
so if i'm boarding a plane to fly back
home to michigan
an anchor thought might be a picture in
my mind of my mom
and i walking on the shores of lake
michigan where i grew up
that's a thought that makes me happy it
makes me excited and it's also related
to the trip that i'm taking if you have
a conversation that you need to have
with your boss
pick an anchor thought about how you
feel
after having that conversation maybe
it's you picking up the phone and
calling somebody that you
you love and saying oh my gosh it went
so well or
you know you walking out of the meeting
and feeling like yeah
i survived that conversation i feel
pretty good about myself
so now that you have your anchor thought
you're ready to beat the fear
if you took money off the table if you
didn't get what anybody else thought
what's the thing you would love to be
doing with your life seriously
do you dream of being a professional
photographer do you want to open your
own restaurant
you always thought about traveling the
world and entertaining kids with
your juggling skills i don't know it's
your life
you get to choose what you want to do be
honest with yourself
what is it that you would want to do
with your life
if you didn't have to pay the bills
doing it another thing you can ask
yourself who do you find yourself sort
of envious of
you know like you look at their life and
you just think gosh how
awesome that they get to do that well
once you have
that answer for yourself you've gotten
really honest you've pushed the [ __ ]
aside and you've really asked it for
yourself
and answered the question honestly all
you gotta do is explore it that's it
just find one thing that you can do
to enrich and expand your knowledge
about it find one course online
google the topic stalk people that are
pursuing this line of work
that's how you start to do it
one step at a time so start with
answering the question what do you
really want
with a massive dose of honesty google
the topic
and find one thing that you can do just
one push yourself
and start to explore if you were to wake
up and do that
every single day spend 10 minutes a day
you would be
startled astonished by what your life
looks like
in a matter of a year or two what is the
biggest
obstacle that we face thiago
it's simple it's self-doubt it's not
fear
it's not lack of money it's not lack of
supporters
it's the fact that deep down inside
you will doubt yourself at critical
moments
and here's the problem with self-doubt
self-doubt doesn't have to stop you
the problem with self-doubt is that the
second that you
feel a little doubtful the second that
you start to question yourself
you physically hesitate that hesitation
has become a habit that stops you
because the moment you hesitate it wakes
up your brain
your brain starts thinking and then you
hold yourself back
you guys know i talk about the five
second rule incessantly it's the title
of the new book that i'm writing that's
coming out
in 2017. the five-second rule
is a tool that battles self-doubt
because in those moments those those
tiny micro moments when you're faced
with
should i do this or should i not should
i speak in a meeting
should i hold back my ideas should i
have this tough conversation or should i
wait till later
the second you doubt the option of
moving forward
you hesitate then you think then you
hold back
that's how it happens every single time
that's how you sabotage your success
that's how you rob yourself
joy that habit
of hesitating the moment that you feel
down
is killing your dreams the single
biggest obstacle in life thiago
is the doubt that you feel and the
single biggest mistake
that you're making is that you hesitate
when you feel it if you start to use the
five second rule in those moments
to just physically move forward within
five
seconds of feeling that doubt
you'll win i need a volunteer coming up
hi how scared are you right now about a
12 or 15 or 30. on a scale of 10
yes good you're perfect okay
so i have an envelope you can either
open this up
and read what it says but you have to do
it
[Music]
how afraid are you for her
or you can give it to somebody
else
now what are you managing right now my
heart rate is just
like out there yeah what do you want to
do life's about change so i'll open it
okay
come up on stage with mel give her a
standing ovation
she deserves it so again
same rules open it up read it to the
audience and then do what it says
how scared are you i'm a little nervous
because i'm not sure what you're going
to want me to do
i'm shy really
that's baloney tell everyone in the
audience the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to you
all right you ready for another one sure
how scared are you
less she'll be speaking at the next
conference you watch
yes i will
congrats lifevantage is paying for your
registration and three-night hostel stay
at the elite academy in orlando
[Music]
it's overwhelmed joy um just the peace i
think that could come with really
choosing to change i believe that
passion
is another word for energy that's it
what do you have energy for what
energizes you
and that we naturally
have a tremendous amount of body wisdom
about that
and that every one of us has an internal
fuel tank
that is either empty or full
and if you're empty you feel depleted
if you're full you feel energized
and so if you simply are in any
situation i mean any situation
and you um pay attention within five
seconds to
does this person energize me do they
deplete me where are they in the scale
you just gain some tremendous wisdom
and you the simple way to start to
figure out who you are and what you want
is start aligning yourself with
more things that energize you so
situationally
if you're lying in bed and the snooze
alarm goes or the alarm goes off
and you feel depleted and you start
reaching for
the snooze button that's a really big
sign
that you need to get out of bed now
being depleted versus energized has
nothing to do with whether or not things
are hard or easy
it has to do with what naturally
actually either
expands you or shrinks you
and so if you look at your client list
and measure it depleted versus energized
what shrinks versus expands me
you have the actual map and when you
start to find the courage to make
decisions
that energize you and that expand you
whether they're scary
or not that's when everything changes
and so that's how i actually make
business decisions
is this i don't even like the money
conversation comes second
it's does this deplete or energize me
and if it depletes me how do you move it
in that direction or how do i
say no if it energizes me how do i do
more because if
you are energized or expanded by
something
you will do it for no money you will do
it
happily and you will suddenly wake up
and say
oh my gosh like my i'm pursuing my
passion
how did that happen a lot of you
feel stuck because you're waiting for
some kind of
external force to either push you
and pressure you to change and to be
great and to be amazing
or you're waiting for somebody to give
you permission
you're either sitting back because you
need some sort of external motivation
from somebody that's going to push you
or praise you or pressure you in order
to change
or some life circumstance like maybe in
your past you've experienced
trauma or you faced something really
scary and that was the thing that made
you change
and then the second thing that people
wait around for is permission look
those may or may not come in your life
if you are somebody
that is sitting around waiting for some
external force to come and do the work
for you
that is such a losing bet it's
unbelievable maybe you'll get lucky
maybe somebody will come but more than
likely
no one is coming the only kind of force
that will truly create change in your
life
is you the internal kind of force
i hate to say it but for those of you
that feel
really really stuck and you keep
thinking that somebody's got to pick me
or somebody's going to discover me or
somebody's got to give me permission to
write this book
it's it's ridiculous this is external
versus internal force
and what you have to figure out if
you're stuck is are you the kind of
person
that is guilty of needing
wanting and waiting for external forces
people an event some outside
force to kick you in the ass so that
you'll finally do the stuff that you've
been dreaming about doing
i want to tell you something no one's
coming
no one the people in life that get what
they
want are the ones that aren't waiting
for an external
force to validate their dreams to
inspire them
to give them permission it's the people
that realize
that success that happiness that control
it comes from the
internal force and what is the internal
force
it's you it's you it's you being able to
realize that no one's going to do the
work for you it's you
realizing that you're never going to
feel ready in fact even as you start
working toward the things that you
really want to do
you're definitely not going to feel
ready and you're going to feel outside
your comfort zone and that's
normal when you start to feel like
you're stretching yourself and you're
sticking your scrawny neck out there and
you're taking
some risks that's amazing because you're
growing
i'm trying to become a fashion and
beauty blogger and mer
and earn money from it full-time but i
have some kind of
mental block and procrastination problem
this is something that we see over
and over and over again and it's this
idea that
you don't ever start you stay
trapped in your head and if you feel
paralyzed if you've been spinning the
same ideas over and over and over again
then you know what i'm talking about you
see
many of you are thinking way too big
you're attaching
way too much pressure on the things that
you're interested in
until you start blogging about fashion
you won't even know if you like it so
thinking that you have a dream about
doing it
and thinking that you have this grand
plan that you're going to do it full
time
it is a complete and utter waste of your
time to be dreaming that big and let me
tell you why
because oftentimes if you're the kind of
person like vicky that's getting trapped
up here
the bigness of what you're thinking
about is what's stopping you
what i want you to do if you're in
vicky's situation is i want you to stop
dreaming and i want you to just start
doing
small things i want you to go back to
curiosity
and less into crushing your big goals
the thing about
life and business and success is that
you have to be willing
to start and for people that
procrastinate
starting is the hardest part for people
that worry for people that think too big
starting is the hardest part folks that
study procrastination talk about the
fact that the only way to beat
procrastination
is to create what they call a starting
ritual which is a way to
push yourself to get started because all
the research shows that if we can push
you to get started on
something you'll likely keep going
i'm the kind of person that believes you
should always make decisions with your
heart and soul
you can use your brain for math you can
use your brain
to look at the fine print in a contract
but when it comes to the actual feel of
the decision
you always want to go inward and check
it against your heart and soul
how do you do that here's the simple
test
does the decision that you're about to
make expand you
expand your future or expand the
possibilities of your life
if the answer is yes then the decision
is yes
no matter how terrifying it is if you
conversely look at the choice that you
have to make
and the decision will shrink you will
silence you
will inhibit you in some way then the
answer is no
no matter how easy the decision is no
matter how safe the decision is the
answer
is no now one of the things i want to
point out that when you start to use
this does it expand or does it shrink me
does it open possibilities or does it
keep things closed
does it raise my voice or does it
silence me right
is that there's always a short-term and
a long-term impact to the decision
the short-term impact to making an
expansive
decision a decision that's faced in your
heart and your soul
sometimes it's terrifying because
sometimes it means moving or it means
changing a job or changing a
relationship or having a difficult
conversation or starting something new
and those sorts of things are always
uncomfortable
so brace for impact put the force fields
up
but make the decision anyway because the
long-term
impact of making a decision from your
heart and soul
that is where the best
life comes from because you're living
for what's true for you not what's safe
in the moment
i hope that helps we spend a lot of time
talking about mindset
from the standpoint of think positives
to positive things happen
and i do believe in having a positive
mindset
obviously i think that the actions that
you take are way more important
in terms of developing that mindset
but we don't spend enough time on what
you were just talking about which is
understanding how the automatic
nature of worrying about
stuff all day long how that
is making you less money how it is
making you less happy
how it is disconnecting you from your
spouse how it is keeping you unhealthy
and how it is a habit that robs you of
joy
and opportunity and power and it is
one of the easiest habits to break
number one your life happens in five
second windows
number two in five seconds
you can control what you think you can
decide what you're gonna do
and you can change absolutely anything
which changes absolutely everything
and so the five second rule is a mind
trick that's all that it is
a fancy way to call it is a you know
it's a form of metacognition
but it's basically a hack it's a cheat
code
okay and the way that it works and this
is the challenge with
getting it out there is that it sounds
so profoundly
stupid like a gimmick
that it took a while for people to
actually
take it seriously i get that and to
really stack up the science to make
you know anybody that interacts with it
go holy sh like this actually works
yeah so here's what it is basically the
moment you catch yourself hesitating
or doubting or starting to worry or
about to chicken out or shrink
or shut up or whatever it is that you're
about to do
that is shrinking your power you just go
five four three two one you count
backwards five four three two one
um what happens when you do that don't
do it out loud because it'll scare
somebody
like a psycho and i mean i'm talking yes
exactly
yes exactly although you know we i i say
it's it's so simple that people this is
a saturday night live skit
in the making right here i can see this
i would love that because that means
i've
really made it true um uh
your kids will use it on you so my kids
will use it on me so if i have a certain
tone that comes out
i'll hear my childhood go 5 4 through
watch that tone mom you know
just um or mom five four three two one i
thought you're gonna go to the gym
um yes so
uh by counting backwards the the
uh kind of cheat code that you're doing
in your mind is you are interrupting
what are called habit loops that get
encoded in the central part of your
brain
and you are starting up the prefrontal
cortex
it's a little trick that causes focus
and it's it's
a lot like having a mantra because
you're shifting gears but
the thing about having a mantra is and i
suppose that as you count backwards more
and more and more
you become used to it but it becomes a
habit
that triggers action so what you do is
go 54321
cut off this part of the brain awaken
this part of the brain and then move
and what happens with the counting
backwards is
there's nowhere to go after one and your
mind
is socialized in a count down situation
to go and so um
counting up won't work because you can
keep going forever
and you do it in many aspects of your
life so it's actually not something that
requires any focus
here's what i do specifically to help
myself
stay focused first things first when i
wake up in the morning
i do not sleep next to my phone the
reason why i don't sleep next to my
phone is because if you sleep next to it
or use it as your alarm
your tendency is to look at it while
you're in bed that means that you're
checking email before you've even
thought about what your priorities are
do not do that
that's tip number one tip number two i
have a pad of
post-it notes yes post-it notes next to
my sink
in my bathroom why well because
after i brush my teeth i haven't looked
at my phone yet
i take a post-it note out and i write
the three things
i need to focus on today
and then you know what i do with it i
stick it on the back of my phone
now why would i do that because i have
my phone with me all the time
and so if it's on the back of my phone
i'm going to get a visual
cue to remind me and keep it top of mind
so i stay focused on it third thing that
i do
it's a little trick i call 30 before 7
30.
what that means i spend 30 minutes
before 7 30 a.m
just focused on getting my day organized
and getting a few of the things that are
my top priorities
either finished or further down the
field
so that's 30 minutes before 7 30 a.m
that's time for me if you utilize
those three things don't sleep with your
phone
right after you brush your teeth write
out your three priorities and stick it
on the back of your phone
just like this and spend 30 minutes
before 7 30 for yourself
i promise you you'll be shocked at how
much more focused
you are and you feel what fascinates me
about human beings
and it fascinates me about um
myself is that we have such
a high tolerance for suckiness isn't it
crazy
as long as the suckiness is a routine
but the second you get thrown out of
your routine or the second
that whether it's because you lose a job
or somebody moves or somebody dies
or somebody breaks up with you or you
break like all of a sudden
that awakens the courage in you to make
a change because
you know either you have no choice or
now you got a problem to solve
but fighting that inertia of life
is the most difficult thing in the world
you know i ended up getting a job
with a law firm because it was the path
of least resistance in boston
in boston i hated it because i went from
being in the courtroom
to writing briefs all day and
luckily i got pregnant with our first
daughter who just is starting college
which makes me feel
so ancient i just want to like punch
myself in the face
i have a 18 year old freshman in college
congratulations
um thank you um but i got pregnant with
her and
when she was born i had horrific
postpartum depression wow
i mean the really scary kind where you
can't be alone with the baby
you're on crazy meds that turn you not
not the kind you take recreationally
yeah these are the kind that
like turn you into a zombie and it was a
really scary thing and i
i when i kind of came out of the
eight-week trance of that i looked up at
chris and said
i've made a decision and he said okay
what would that be
and i said i don't ever want to answer
the question
what do you do for a living
with the response i'm a lawyer and he
said
okay you realize we've just bought this
house and we have a kid
and uh we have bills to pay and he said
so here's the deal
you've got exactly four weeks before
your maternity leave is over
you need to make sixty thousand dollars
i don't care what you do for a living
that's your problem go solve it and the
night before i was supposed to
so i networked like a crazy person
because again
if you're a human being with a problem
you'll solve it yeah
and so if it matters enough to you and
so uh
i i got a job and this was the first.com
boom
in boston i got a job the night before i
was supposed to go back
too many of you are sitting around
waiting to feel
ready you can still move forward when
you're not ready
too many of you are waiting to feel like
you deserve
to make six figures it's about the
action
your mind your history your past
you will always have a million excuses
not to do it not to feel like it not to
believe in yourself they're all
the only thing that matters in your life
and your business is the actions that
you're taking
and the more consistently that you take
action the
faster you will start to believe in
yourself because you will
see proof that you are not the kind of
person that sits around and feels
unworthy
that you're not a victim that sits by
and gets sucked into other people's
stuff
that you're not that kind of person so
it won't make sense to believe it
anymore but it starts
with action i believe in all of you
and i believe in your ability to get it
done but it's going to be up to you
who is the problem
yeah who's the solution i am that's
right
don't wait to feel like that is the
biggest mistake you could possibly make
remember that you're smart remember that
you know what to do
and just get it done i've been in the
media business for 10 years
when i tell you that things have changed
1 000
let me just give you an example my first
media deal i was signed by
abc that's right abc the big dog crazy
syndicated shows i was signed by them to
do a talk show deal now do you know what
that meant
there was some executive that was
looking out over the sea of talent
they were meeting with agents they were
picking people they were doubting you
and then guess what if they did pick you
they owned everything they told you what
to do
oprah's an anomaly the game was
gatekeepers
a few media players a sea of competition
total scarcity now what is it today holy
it's unbelievable if you have an iphone
you can have a show
if you have an idea and you're willing
to put it out there and you're willing
to start
sharing yourself on social media you
have a syndication
platform there is no one doubting you
except for you and that's why i'm
sitting here imploring you i'm telling
you right now if you have a business
if you have aspirations if you have a
dream the single
biggest opportunity in front of you is
to put it out on social media
to start talking about the things that
interest you to start sharing your ideas
sharing and documenting what you're up
to i guarantee you you start doing that
and you're gonna start amassing an
audience that you had no idea was out
there dying
to connect with you to learn from you
and to grow with you
i gave a speech yesterday in dallas
after the speech
it was a big audience of people in
financial services
a guy dressed to the nines and like one
of these super slick suits comes up to
me he says
hey mel you know really love the five
second rule
do you mind if i give you some feedback
feedback
don't you hate getting feedback and then
when people actually preface it by
saying can i give you some feedback i
don't know about you but
literally my butt's like it just cannot
stand it i immediately go on edge
but here's the thing about feedback you
have to take it you have to take it it
is critical
critical critical critical so i want to
tell you number one what the guy said to
me
my reaction and then i want to give you
my philosophy
about feedback because what the guy said
to me
was so valuable and it was also really
hard for me to hear
here i am after the speech we're
surrounded by a big group of people he
walks up to me and says when it's his
turn in the line can i give you some
feedback i immediately tense up
and this is what he says mel i love the
concept of the five second rule
super cool idea can't wait to try it
okay now comes the punch in the gut he
said you called it
so many times during the speech it was
off
pudding doesn't that sound terrible that
word and he said i could tell that you
were doing it on purpose
he's right in fact you called it so many
times and yet you have these insanely
powerful examples of how people are
using it
you came off as defensive when he
said this to me i literally you know how
you feel like you're shrinking
in life or you're like standing in your
full size then all of a sudden somebody
says something you're like i just want
to disappear right now and the reason
why i was such a zinger is he was right
he was absolutely right you see i do
call the five second rule
because i'm in front of so many
analytical audiences
i'm in front of skeptics all the time
and so i use it as a preemptive way to
disappear
the biggest pushback on the five second
rule which is on
its face it sounds so so simple there's
no way it could be so powerful the
problem is i've gotten lazy and i say it
too much
he's 100 right and by hearing that
feedback i can make a really
simple tweak to my speech i can call it
once or twice in the very beginning and
then i can transition to calling it
something that's very simple and
powerful now that's going to help me
reach more people with the five second
rule and here's what i want to say about
feedback
feedback is intense to receive it really
is
because you are exposing yourself to
critical
opinions it will make you feel very
vulnerable the way that i handle
feedback
and process it i'm very clear about the
things that i will receive feedback on
and i'm very clear about the things that
i will not receive
feedback on and the reason why is if you
don't listen to
any feedback at all guys you're never
going to improve you're not going to
ever do
anything new so no feedback means
nothing new
if you listen to everything that
everybody says
in terms of feedback if you allow
everybody to weigh in
on everything it's going to become so
paralyzing that you will do nothing new
so the key with feedback is knowing
yourself
and knowing what you actually accept
feedback on and knowing what you don't
accept feedback on
my life changed a couple years ago when
i discovered something called the
progress
principle it is a principle that
was written about in the harvard
business review it's based on
a tremendous amount of research done by
a professor over there and what she
determined is that
people that feel uh happy and successful
and fulfilled by their lives and work
they all have one thing in common they
feel as though they're making progress
on something that matters
so i read this little bit of research
and i started applying it to my life
and what i do as as this sounds it
really works i don't focus on balancing
everything i focus on just
making sure that i make progress
on one thing a day that's right you
heard me
one thing a day that matters to me
now if i can make progress on one thing
a day that matters to me
then i can let go and let the rest of my
day get hijacked by
kids by spouse by phone calls by emails
by social media by
all kinds of things that come up and
tend to hijack your day when you're a
busy
person when you have a family when
you're married when you got a lot going
on
and so by focusing on one thing a day
i feel the sense of control and the
sense of progress that science tells us
will make you happy
and make you feel more confident and
actually make you more effective at
getting things done
it also frees me up to be more present
with my kids so many of us have this
perfectionism gene
and the reason why we're perfectionists
is we're trying
to insulate ourselves from criticism
that if you get it perfect no one will
give you feedback
if you get it right nobody's going to
criticize you
if you do it perfect then no one will be
able to attack you
and the problem with that and that's
just another side of the same
coin which is the fear of disappointing
people you're managing not disappointing
people not by lying and not by being
codependent but by actually trying to be
a perfectionist so that nobody
criticizes you
so let me tell you a story about the
fear of disappointing people in my own
life
because this is the biggest trigger in
my life i mean it goes back to being in
fourth grade right
it's there and this is another thing i i
literally have to remind myself of this
everybody
every single day you cannot remove the
things that trigger you
you can't if you've been doing a pattern
since fourth grade there will be things
for the rest of your life
that will trigger that pattern to come
up but you can always choose
not to repeat the pattern so you'll be
triggered and be afraid
that you're going to disappoint somebody
that's real that's normal it's natural
it's part of being a human being
i think it's interwoven into every
relationship where you love somebody
but you don't have to behave the way
that you always behaved when you're
nervous about disappointing somebody so
let me give you a dumb story you ready
when my husband and i got
married my father gave us this really
incredible gift
he gave us an antique pool table i grew
up in muskegon michigan where brunswick
was founded
and my dad has a hobby of going to
garage sales and estate sales
and buying old dilapidated pool tables
and then he restores them so when chris
and i got married
he bought us an old dilapidated pool
table from the same
era as our house which is the 1870s he
restored the whole thing
and then recently he and i rented a
u-haul and we drove this sucker
from muskegon michigan to boston
massachusetts my dad and i took a road
trip
get there and we assemble the pool table
in what used to be our playroom fast
forward three or four years
the speaking business takes off my
business starts to grow
we have people that work for us and my
kids are older
we don't need a playroom we need an
office the pool table is in the middle
of this thing
for the first two years of having the
office we kept the pool table there
why because i didn't want my dad to be
disappointed because i love him
now he visits our house twice a year
for two or three days with my mom and i
kept this thing
occupying a third of our office for two
years and then i realized
i'm being ridiculous i'm being
absolutely ridiculous now here's the
thing
will he be disappointed if i take the
pool table down absolutely definitely
there are always going to be things that
you do decisions that you have to make
in your life in your business for your
family
that will disappoint other people it's
unavoidable but the fact that he's going
to be disappointed
should never be the reason that i don't
do
something that is aligned with my values
now let's take it a step further when
you make a decision
that is likely going to disappoint
people or that does
still make the decision because it's
your life there's
nothing worse than when you start to rob
your future and your life and your
happiness
because you're so focused on other
people however if you love people
you can still take care of them when you
make that decision so let me go back to
the example of the pool table so i knew
i was going to take it down i knew my
father was going to be disappointed
i was disappointed i don't have a big
house so i don't
you know i don't have the room for a
huge pool table i don't have a finished
basement like a lot of people
i don't have like a cool garage game
room thing like i just don't have it
i called him first and said i need to
talk to you about something
you know the pool table i love the pool
table dad my business is growing so much
i actually need an office
and oh great it'll be great in the
office and i'm like well
yeah it would except i have you know
three or four people showing up and we
got to put some desks in there
for now even went down well you could
put a piece of plywood they could work
on the pool table and then they could do
the thing and then the thing
and now my heart is racing because i
don't want to disappoint my dad and now
he's fighting for the and i had to just
say for me
dad here's what's going to happen i'm
going to hire professional movers
in the pool table business to
disassemble this with love and care
we're going to store it beautifully
when i either get a full-time office off
site or i build a barn
or i build a different house this will
have
its own beautiful room dedicated to you
so we had this beautiful conversation
now was he disappointed
absolutely when they come to the house
and visit which they just did
and they walk into the office do i feel
a pang
you better believe i do it doesn't
matter that's all normal
i still need to make the decisions that
i need to make and the difference
what's changed is how i relate to that
fear
so instead of what i would do in the
past is i would make a
decision that doesn't serve me i'd leave
the pool table and then i'd be all about
it
i'd leave the pool table as a way to
make my dad happy but it makes me
miserable to leave it there because i
need the space right
and then i'd be kind of annoyed and then
he'd come
and i'd fake play pool because i kind of
want to run you know you know what i'm
saying like we do all this
that's not real and what i've been able
to do
for myself in some instances when i
catch it
is to hit it head on and to be authentic
and to still take care of people and
what i've also come to learn
is that people can be disappointed in
you and they still love you
you know you're never going to get
around this everybody in your family is
going to be disappointed with you
probably once a day
probably and you have the ability to
retrain
how you respond to that trigger that
rises up in you where you start to
fear that you're disappointing somebody
and the answer really is
make the decision that's aligned with
your values and the thing that supports
you
and then take care of the person by
being honest
and straightforward about it dealing
with their disappointment head on
because that's really the adult thing to
do and that's what you do when you love
somebody
the way we've all been handling it
myself included is manipulation
lying resentment withholding and
that doesn't serve anybody i'm about to
change your life
because this piece of research changed
mine
procrastination has nothing to do with
work
the people that write to us the most
that struggle with procrastinating
phd students engineers entrepreneurs
people that have a lot on their plate
that have a lot of things that they need
to juggle
and that are analytical and thinkers by
nature
procrastination is a form of stress
relief
what are you stressed about
bingo and it makes you upset doesn't it
yeah
how many of you can relate to that she
said that what's stressing her out
is she wants to retire she hasn't saved
up enough
money what's really stressing you out is
finances and money and the fear
that you have what happens when you
struggle with procrastinating and thank
you for being so honest
there's that stresses you out maybe you
feel the same way
and we felt that way i know exactly what
you're talking about you carry around
this
dark cloud because you don't think
you're gonna make it you're stressed
about money all the time
or maybe your mom's health is declining
and it really stresses you out
or maybe your best friends are going
through a divorce or you're going
through a divorce and that really
stresses you out
and so you walk around with this big ass
thing on your shoulders
all the time and then you walk into work
and you sit down and you've got a list
of phone calls to make
which requires your prefrontal cortex
and your prefrontal cortex looks at the
list and it's like oh my god
you want me to make 15 phone calls i've
been worried about the money all day can
we just look at cat videos
i need a break and next thing you know
two hours is gone you've been online
shopping you've been looking at cat
videos
and then of course you look at the 15
phone calls you're like i didn't make
them i didn't make them i didn't make
them the research on procrastination
is undeniable it's black and white
number one
all of you that procrastinate
procrastination's not the issue at
stress
you're procrastinating to give yourself
a little break at work
it's sort of like taking a smoking break
almost you know you're just taking a
break
so number one because you're all
stressed out and procrastinators are
very hard on yourselves this is going to
sound super
but you got to forgive yourself you have
got to actually
have a talk with yourself where you feel
yourself starting to procrastinate you
go
look you know i really screwed up i know
i'm going to mess financially i forgive
myself
i'm just going to do the best that i can
so you have to address the thing that's
underneath it
so that self-awareness of knowing oh my
god here's that stress again
about finances screwing me over and
preventing me from doing the small
things that will actually fix my
finances
second thing that you're gonna do
procrastination's a habit right you get
triggered by stress
the habit is to procrastinate so when
you get triggered by stress
your new habit is oh there's my stress
again i'm gonna actually
tell myself okay you've done the best
you can it's okay we're gonna do a
little bit today you're gonna create
what we call starting ritual
a starting ritual is something that
pushes you to start the best one on the
planet the five second rule so you've
said okay there's my stress again
i forgive myself now we're gonna five
four three two one i want you to only
work for five minutes
that's it five minutes make phone calls
for five minutes here's what we know
based on the research eighty percent of
you will keep going
the trick is starting you see i want to
break
the connection between the trigger which
is stress
and the response which is
procrastination and whenever you feel
stressed which is normal
you have a choice here's that gap in
five seconds flat
the habit of procrastinating and beating
yourself up will take over
or you can close the gap five four three
two one
and you can make a different choice i'm
just gonna get started i'm just gonna be
okay with where i'm at and i'm just
gonna get started
got it good i want to address
my comments to those of you that have
learned the five second rule you've
tried the countdown 54321
and it's not working i gotta level with
you
the five second rule always works it's
backed by science
and it has helped change the lives of
millions of people
the problem is not the rule the problem
is
you actually don't want to change
i'm dead serious i want i want you to
just stop and think about that for a
minute
for people who try to count down but
then don't actually push themselves
forward
for those of you that that are
struggling with self-doubt struggling to
get up on time struggling to make the
calls to grow your business struggling
to stay motivated you know about the
five-second rule but you don't
use it there's a simple reason why
you're not using it
you don't want to change look change is
hard i get it
if you're gonna change anything about
your life you're gonna have to face the
unknown you're gonna have to step out of
your comfort zone you're gonna have to
try something new you're gonna have to
risk rejection and judgment
it's scary i get it that's why most
people never
change so if you're like leanne
and you've got all the tools at your
disposal but you
still are stuck the reason why you're
stuck is you don't want to change yet
so stop complaining about the tools
and go inward and actually examine what
are you afraid of
seriously what do you get out of staying
stuck what do you
get from staying heavy what do you get
from not making the money that you want
what do you
get from dating a string of losers you
get safety
i don't know you get the ability to
complain are you the one that's
constantly dominating all your
friendships because you're constantly
griping about how bad your life is i
don't know what you're getting out of it
but you're getting something
the moment you decide that you're sick
and tired of it the moment that you
decide that you are
so ready to change the five second rule
this puppy right here the five four
three two one it'll be there
and it'll work and look when you start
deciding that it's time to change you
may have to use five four three two one
five thousand times a day
for weeks on end because you're pushing
through self-doubt and you're pushing
through procrastination and you're
pushing through resignation and you're
pushing through fear over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again
and then what's going to happen and i
see this happening around the world
i know that it works we have proof that
it works if you use 54321
and you push through everything that's
stopping you right now because you
this is your year this is the moment
that you're going to change
at some point something's going to click
and the momentum is going to kick in
and suddenly change isn't going to be
scary
change is going to be what's happening
worrying about
things that could go wrong and staying
in that space undermines my ability
to solve it to be present and it robs me
of my full thinking capacity if you
catch yourself
chronically worrying it means you have a
habit and it will
very much lead to anxiety there is a
direct correlation between
your habit of worrying and then that
becoming anxiety so worry is a baby
anxiety is the big sister because
anxiety just means that the bad
thoughts are now manifesting as physical
symptoms
in your body your stomach hurts your
throat is tight you're sweating
your heart races and a panic attack is
when your mind gets concerned
because your body state is agitated so
it takes over and gets you out of
whatever
situation you're in and so you want to
go to war
against your habit of worrying use your
worries
as a quick signal that there's something
to fix or pay attention to
but do not under any circumstances allow
yourself to become the kind of person
that wastes your precious lifetime
sitting there
spinning cycles it's like washing the
same load of laundry over
and over and over again it's a total
waste of time
and it will erode your happiness and it
will make you
ineffective at getting the things that
you want in your life
i know that everybody's problem comes
down to one pattern you're repeating
that you can't see
and that pattern is getting triggered by
something that happened in your past
that left you with this emotional scar
and so for me the thing that i always
always always have to deal with in
myself is the fear of disappointing
somebody so if i'm in a situation where
i start to feel that it's an old trigger
and so when you finally have a word that
describes in a visceral way this thing
you hate about yourself or this thing
that triggers you
or whatever it may be um that's where
the power comes because now you can name
the thing that
was once controlling you and so if you
can identify first of all the pattern
you keep repeating
that makes you miserable or doesn't
serve you or makes you lose your power
or has you go numb
then you can start to go back and say
well where did i where did i first start
doing this
and what was the experience that
triggered it because that's the root of
the problem
right there and when you expose all of
that the trigger and the emotional
button like my i'm afraid of
disappointing people i'm afraid of
disappointing people i'm not worthy i'm
not worthy you know i'm pissed off that
i
that this is happening to me now you
have the ability to change it forever
my night routine is very simple complete
the day and leave
no tasks that i have to finish in the
morning it's that that
that's it and so it's not necessarily
that i have a specific order
but there are particular things that i
do number one totally set up the kids so
that means
pack their lunches it means get the
backpacks ready if it's school season
and get them by the door
it means if there's any forms that need
to be filled out or printed or anything
else if they are printed they are ready
to go so kids are
handled second thing i want the kitchen
clean
i don't ever want to wake up in the
morning and walk in there and see
crap that i have to do i don't want
dishes in the sink i don't want
things on the counter and so i make sure
that the kitchen is clean
that the counters are cleared off and
that
there is no nothing i need to do in the
kitchen because it will distract me in
the morning i will feel
guilt i will feel obligated to get that
done
um third thing that i do is i tend to
set out
the stuff for breakfast and the reason
why i do that
is because my kids will wake up at
various times
and so if i've got that thing set up
i've just bought myself a couple more
minutes of quiet in the morning before
the parade of children come running down
the stairs
starving and wanting breakfast the other
thing that i do is i go to my computer
and i print out the day
calendar for the day ahead
and then i take that printout and i take
my
notebook that has all of my travel and
kind of everything that's laid out for
the the business that i run and my
speaking schedule and
stuff related to the kids and i move it
all to the kitchen now why am i doing
this
i'm doing this so that when i leave my
bedroom
in the morning and i walk into the
kitchen to have 30 minutes of quiet time
for myself to get focused
to plan my priorities everything's set
it's all been handled there's no
thinking involved it's amazing
then once that's all handled i turn off
all the lights
i lock the front door when i walk into
my bedroom the very
first thing that i do i set my alarm
and then i plug my phone in in my closet
that is the single most important aspect
of my evening routine
you know i'm always looking for new ways
to explain the power of the five-second
rule and the power of five-second
decisions
and i read something that tim ferriss
said that really resonated with me
and he had this one line buried in a
podcast somewhere
that just jumped out and it's it's it's
stuck
and what he said is he said something
about how there's a gap
between the world and the things that
trigger you
and your response and your entire
life is that gap when you start to
this is not what he said he i kind of
identified this gap and i
of course intrinsically was like well
absolutely that's the five second window
between instinct or stimulus
and your reaction and when you start to
understand
that your whole life plays out in this
five second gap
and that there's a gap that's five
seconds long between
fear and courage and there's a gap
that's five seconds long between
self-doubt and confidence that is
your life and what's super cool about
understanding
that your whole life is inside this gap
is it's so small
everybody that you have the ability to
control it life's always
going to throw triggers at you and there
will always be all kinds of cool things
that inspire you your wisdom
and you get to choose what happens in
that gap
do you succumb to an excuse or do you
push yourself forward
when you start to speak up in business
you'll be shocked at how you start to
speak up and your relationships
when you start to make hard phone calls
whether it's in a selling situation
you'll be surprised at how you'll start
to close the gap and have hard
conversations
in your personal life and so that gap is
everywhere and it's the same everywhere
and when you start to go
to work in controlling how you live in
that gap
between stimulus or idea and your
response that's where the magic is
other than the five-second rule there is
one
habit that i have adopted in the last
three years
that has fundamentally changed me as a
business person
and it has also changed my ability to
manage my
emotions so i don't get hijacked i do
not
allow my phone in the bedroom
i know the research deloitte just did a
study based on phone use alone and 33
of people are reading emails in the
middle of the night
i know that if you go to bed and the
phone is right next to you
right so you go to bed because you need
your phone you know somebody might need
you and you sleep
you know if this is right here and it's
not closed and the blue light is on
they've done studies where
you have people at a table and the
researcher will put their phone on the
table
not even my phone the researcher's phone
and the brain lights up like crazy
just with the presence of a phone the
research around the phone and sleep is
so
stunning that if you were to adopt one
radical thing today other than the five
second rule try
putting your phone outside your bedroom
turn off the zip
so you don't hear it tell people who
need to reach you to call you
my kids i have a kid in college a kid
who's you know high school
kid in middle school if there's an
emergency
call me there is nothing happening on
your phone at two o'clock in the morning
that's important but if
you allow yourself to become a tool
of this this is supposed to be your tool
for selling
your tool for communicating and we're
all becoming the tool here's the other
thing common sense wise that i want you
to understand
you wake up the alarm goes off
what do you do so you're not even
vertical and you're reading emails
and what is in these emails other
people's crap
if you don't have boundaries with this
puppy it's going to impact sleep it's
going to impact how much money you make
it's going to impact how much
self-control you have and so
when i put this thing outside the
bedroom
and i wake up i walk over to where the
phone is it's plugged into my bathroom i
turn it off i don't look at it yet
i give myself five minutes five minutes
before i tune into the world
to actually tune in up here and say
what's the one thing i'm going to get
done today
that really matters to me if you're the
kind of person that feels like you don't
have control over your day that your day
gets hijacked that you can't get to the
priorities that you're always behind the
ball
this one planning thing will change your
life no phone in the bedroom
turn it off when the alarm goes off five
minutes five lousy minutes
five lousy minutes before you tune in to
the rest of the world
and if you've got the kind of job where
you've got to check it get up 10 minutes
earlier
you have control over this stuff and it
is so important that you take it
seriously now because
you're living at the slowest moment of
your entire life this is a huge mistake
that people make in marketing that
so many newsletters are me what am i
thinking
and whenever we sit and write the
newsletter we're thinking about
what is the most valuable thing because
somebody has actually invited us
into their inbox and that is a
critical question in marketing that most
people are not asking themselves or
spamming people and
they're doing only shits about them and
they're not thinking about
why does somebody subscribe to me and
when
we write that newsletter and it's why it
is so incredibly
successful and why people love it we're
always thinking about
does this interest or help
or entertain the person that's reading
it and you know any time that it turns
out to be too much of us talking about
us
somebody on the team catches it thank
god because there's nothing more
annoying than having somebody go
on and on and on about all the cool
they're doing versus thinking about what
are some
interesting hacks and and links and cool
things that we can
introduce people to that might improve
their work or their life
langley writes from nigeria i'm
passionate about film and
cinema mel i tweet and i blog about it
people are inspired by what i write
but when i'm offered certain
opportunities i clench up and suddenly
feel like an imposter who will mess up
and be found i'm 36
i'm single in a paycheck to paycheck
situation
and feel like i have wasted many years
due to overthinking
self-doubt and never feeling good enough
or ready
how can i overcome this well you can't
you can't
overcome the feelings that are rising up
langley
but you can take action despite them
that's a very important distinction that
i want each and every one of you to
understand
the things that you're feeling clenching
up feeling like you're not good enough
feeling like you're not ready
doubting yourself kind of spending too
much time
thinking about how much time you've
wasted all that
that's normal that we all do you cannot
overcome those thoughts because they
keep rising up and they've become a
habit and it's sort of a pattern
so i don't want you to focus on the
thoughts i want you to focus
on taking action even though you doubt
yourself
you are going to feel like an imposter
until you push
through that clenched up moment over and
over and over again
and then suddenly through action langley
you're gonna see that you're not an
imposter at all
you're actually the kind of person that
pushes through
and does what he or she says they are
going to do
if you want to be successful in business
if you truly want that side hustle to
turn into your full-time thing
you have to learn how to let
the feelings of doubt rise up
but take action anyway i had tremendous
success success
in the speaking business my i went from
zero never had been paid for a speech to
literally the most booked woman in the
world in three years flat
crazy there's a number of reasons why
number one the content's terrific
i'm also a really good public speaker
there's not a lot of women on the
circuit but more importantly
i behave in a way because i know that
the number
one asset in business is make the people
you're dealing with
know that they matter take care of
everybody you deal with
everybody the event planners the
speaking bureaus
everybody has something that they're
worried about you
get rid of the worry you make them feel
like they're important everybody wants
to be around you
because at the end of the day we all
want to know that we matter so if you
do business with people that make you
feel good you want to do more business
with them
and so it's a really really simple thing
i call my philosophy about human beings
is just be a fan
just cheer for everybody there's so much
success to go around
people have really difficult lives they
make things really hard for themselves
make their life easy make them feel
great give them a hug
smile compliment them be generous don't
be a pain in the ass like literally
it's that simple i realize that i need
to have
a level of focus and a level of
intentionality that i have not yet
cultivated in my life that there's still
that i do
that i put in the way that was fine when
i was operating and achieving at this
level
but now i want to go to this level and
so what are those things getting up
earlier
being a complete hawk
about how i'm spending my time and
attention
that in the mornings when i'm with my
family literally being hyper focused
unjust them so that i'm present with
them and then
confession i'll literally work for like
25 minutes and then the add kicks in and
then i'll find myself folding laundry
for 20 minutes because i allow myself to
get distracted and see that's the thing
about
habits and the levels of success that
you get to that when you recognize that
jumping to the next level that you want
to get to is nothing more than just
tweaking your habits a little bit that
it's really that
simple you will start to be able to have
quantum leaps and i'm realizing that i
have amazing habits but they
have gotten me to hear and if i want to
get to the next level it's going to
require a level of focus and
intentionality that i haven't demanded
of myself before
no drinking during the week being super
super
focused on the stuff that's really
important probably hiring somebody
full-time to be a full-time
assistant to help me stay organized and
focused in terms of scheduling and
weeding through all the incoming
requests i think it's just about that
about this
sort of like maniacal focus on things
that are important like now is the time
and
what's cool is you can make it happen
anytime in your life like if there's
some jump that you want to make look i'm
an extraordinarily productive person
i've accomplished a tremendous amount in
the last three years
but what it's going to take for me to
get to the next level and not destroy
the people around me with my stress and
be an amazing leader and be an amazing
mother
and be an awesome wife and actually be
an incredible businesswoman is a level
of focus that i have never required of
myself i've been getting a ton
of questions about being paralyzed with
the fear of what other people think and
this is so commonplace i think every
human being on the planet is
is paralyzed in some aspect or some area
of their life because they're
concerned about with their parents or
what their friends or with their friends
on facebook or with their colleagues or
what their upline or their downline or
whatever
what their neighbors are gonna think if
you are struggling with this
and you have not found it helpful to
attack your thinking patterns then
here's a trick that i want you to try
to break the pattern of being paralyzed
by what other people think i want you to
pick
one thing one thing that you've been
wanting to do
that you've been thinking about but you
have stopped yourself
from doing because you're concerned
about what other people think let me
give you some examples maybe you've
wanted to go on a wellness retreat
but you think your spouse will roll
their eyes at you so you haven't done it
maybe you have a particular facebook
post or a blog
so many of you want to start a business
or start creating art but you're
terrified of putting yourself out there
because of what other people will think
today
we're going to break that pattern what
you're going to do is you're going to
pick one thing
you've been stopping yourself from doing
and you're going to do it you're going
to do it and the reason why i want you
to do this
is because i know that if you're still
paralyzed
you have not been able to change your
thinking patterns yet that's cool no
problem we're gonna try a different
tactic i want you to change
this paralysis through action because if
you sign up for that class
if you go on that retreat if you create
your art if you post that blog post if
you start that business
you will be proving to yourself through
the actions that you're taking
that you don't care what other people
think try that today
let me know number one what you've
stopped yourself from doing and number
two what you're committing to doing
today
because one way to break this is to
attack the thoughts and change the
thoughts and get into action first
the other way to do it is to recognize
that you're paralyzed
pick one thing that you're gonna do and
actually get it
done i can't remember where who i
learned this from
but i was recently somebody else said oh
well you know instead of saying sorry
try saying thank you
so when you run into a meeting and
you're late oh sorry i'm late or to a
call
say thank you for your patience and that
one line
has changed everything for me and what
i've come to realize is that when i say
i'm sorry it's all about me and i'm
making myself wrong and when i say thank
you i'm actually acknowledging the other
people around me and you can find that
you can substitute that line in almost
every instance and i was very surprised
by how often without even thinking about
it i was saying sorry i was telling
everybody the story that even yesterday
i was in a yoga class and somebody fell
over on the you know and kind of hit me
and i'm like oh i'm sorry
what you know no i but just like i could
have said are you okay
instead of i'm sorry the other thing i
use so much qualifying language when i
speak
and i never knew it until i was on cnn
and then you have the horrifying
experience of having to watch yourself
on video i had no idea how often i said
i think
or actually or you know like all of
these
qualifiers maybe yeah it takes the
precision
and the force out of your language and
the way that you speak
and i had no idea how often i was being
equivocal
we were hiking with our kids we have two
teenage kids and we were up in the
presidential range in new hampshire and
we were having a conversation about
social media and our daughter said
something that i want everybody to take
to heart
she said your social life today
is all about what everybody else is
doing
and i think the same is true with
business success
too many of us fall into the trap of
defining
our business success by what other
people are doing and so if you get just
one thing
from our conversation today other than a
gigantic kick in the ass from both peter
and me
i want you to understand that your
highest
value proposition is you
there is only one you you have
inner wisdom you have a unique set of
experiences you have struggles
all of that is yours and so yes
look around at what other people are
doing and and
and draw inspiration from it but then
pull it back in
and check it against what your wisdom is
telling you what your definition of
success is
got a great question about dealing with
relationships friendships where
you have a close friend who's a real
downer
and they've got all kinds of issues and
they are draining
the you know what out of your energy it
happens all the time
i'm going to say a couple things about
this i have something that i call the
six month rule for the people in your
life your friends
your family people are going to go
through ups and downs and i think it's
super super
super important that you be there for
people that you listen to the things
that they're struggling with that you
give advice that you help them find
resources
you must must must do that this is part
of being an incredible friend
however when the issue sticks around so
long
that your friendship spirals into a
situation where
that friendship is nothing more than you
listening to somebody complain
and now it's zapping your energy now
it's time for you to change how you're
behaving in the friendship so this is
why i call it the six month rule
for six months absolutely listen to
somebody give them all the advice be the
shoulder they cry on let them [ __ ] and
kvich and all that stuff
to you all day long but if after six
months your friend
is still complaining and doing nothing
and is still complaining and acting
helpless
is still stuck in that rut and refusing
to take your advice it's really
important that you draw some boundaries
and it's
important for you it's also important
for your friend so here's what you're
going to do you're basically just going
to say look i love you
i know you're going through a hard time
but i will no longer listen to you
complain about it
and the reason why is because it's not
helping you and
it's really starting to make me sad that
you're still this stuck and you're not
taking action
let's definitely hang out let's spend a
lot of time together but we're not
allowed to talk about this anymore
the second you start taking action to
fix the situation
we can talk about it again and you know
that i'm here for you but i'm not here
for you so that you can stay stuck
i'm here for you so that you can get
better so that you can grow i've always
wanted a six-pack and i don't have it
and i don't know and i've never had it
and
when i i finally stopped complaining
about it
when i got honest about what it was
going to require
oh i'm dead serious dead serious about
this at my
you know at 49 with my affinity for
alcohol
and my love of carbs and my taste for
exercise
i have a small problem on my hands if i
want a six pack
so if you were to go forward right and
think okay well if a year from now i had
a six-pack
what would what would that actually what
would my day-to-day life look like
and you can get very clear that you're
not committed to that
and then you can stop beating yourself
up for the sh you never intend on doing
what i realized is i can spend four
minutes a day
in a hotel room or in my bedroom doing
planks and my arms look great and
everybody else will think the rest of my
body's in shape
and we're good we're good yes
[Applause]
it looks like a charm so you might want
to get honest with yourself
like instead of doing this i don't want
to be a millionaire
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
but you're gonna have to roll the clock
forward just a year and say okay
if i'm able to put
a thousand dollars a month against my
debt i'm able to
make x amount of dollars a month i'm
able to put x amount of dollars in
savings what do i need to be doing a
year from now to make that happen and
what are those habits that are there
a year from now that i don't have right
now
and then roll yourself back to this
moment just like i explained with
exercise
do i actually not want to have a
manhattan tonight nope did i want to go
to the gym today
nope did i would am i
am i willing to not eat what i ate for
nope
am i willing i did my four minutes my
arms are looking really good
but so bring it back and then you will
have the formula for pivoting
at any moment you time travel forward a
year
you investigate the patterns that you
have that are giving you the result that
you want and then you back your ass up
to right here right now
and you decide am i willing to do this
now if i'm willing
then 54321 through all the excuses that
are going to be there when you're trying
to override your operating system
that's how you do it or you have the
reality check like i had which is oh
i just like i don't intend on changing
so why don't we
get this off the plate and let's focus
on the things that i am actually
committed to
so in the ted talk i cited this this
statistic that i had read
uh years ago and that is that a
scientist had calculated the odds of you
and me being born
and when you think about just even the
sexual act of your parents in a lifetime
relationship the number of times they
would actually be intimate
the amount of sperm that go the the
odds of one egg and one sperm and then
you throw in
then you throw in the dna and the
uniqueness
of your dna structure some scientists
calculated all of those odds and figured
out that the odds of you being you
who you are born the day that you were
born to the parents that you have
with the dna structure that you have
given
all the other variables that could have
changed something
the odds are one in 400 trillion that
you are you and so what that means to me
is that you're meant to be here that
there is a reason why you were born and
the journey of your life
is to figure it out and i think it's
actually
simple i think that life is very
simple and we complicate it because we
have brains that can tell stories
and we have um bodies that can
sense danger and so we over
complicate things and the the purpose of
your life
is to listen to your heart and soul and
to follow it
and to express the highest version of
you
not the self-doubt not the anxiety not
the fears not the pettiness not the
frustrations but to actually have the
courage
to be fully expressed as
as like it sounds stupid but you know as
the as a great human being to have the
courage to be kind to have the courage
to be patient to have the courage to
cheer for other people
and have the courage to tune into that
wisdom that's inside of you
and lean into it follow the things that
pique your curiosity
do more of the that actually expands
your heart and expands
the amount of energy in your body and
slowly but surely if you align all your
decisions
and the things that you spend time on
and the people that you spend time on
with the things that naturally energize
you your whole life will experience a
that shift of like i need to get off of
this because
we'll be i'll be spending time with like
my fiance or with my family
i it popped into my head oh my gosh i
need to text this person i forgot i
needed to
call and get this order fixed how do you
find that shift to just say you know
what
i'm spending time with my family and
i'll do it tomorrow but not
like in a procrastinating it's an
excellent question
i think if you're present to whether or
not
you're kind of in the zone of time where
it's cool to be fluid
you're kind of with the family you're
also sort of present on your phone
that's cool if you've decided that
because
my kids are starting to complain or my
fiance's starting to complain
that i'm always like this then you got
honor
that if you're gonna say i'm putting
down the phone between
seven and nine o'clock tonight and i'm
actually just going to be present with
you you've got to honor it
so what i will do is i'll just jot a
note to myself
so instead of picking up the phone i'll
just jot a note down you've had the
experience right where you got to
like be in a meeting at the school or
you have to catch a plane
or you've got a doctor's appointment and
have you ever noticed that when you've
got an anchor like that
your whole day condenses and you're more
productive because you've got this
deadline
and that's called parkinson's law so
parkinson's law
it's a research-backed fact that when
you have work to do
it will expand to the amount of time
that you have to do it in so if you have
20 minutes to make a call
how long will it take you if you have
two weeks to make it how long will it
take you
correct so if you every day
no phone in your room you set that one
priority that matters to you if you got
time to kind of inch it forward just a
little bit great you've already made
progress
you're done for the day then you look at
your phone you also set a quitting time
right then and there
the majority of days you'll honor it and
that quitting time means
for me it means i'm not on my phone and
everybody that works for me
if knows if there's an emergency or if
we have to do something they'll call me
so that that helps a lot if you had to
pick
one word that was you
one word that represented your essence
and so let me explain what i mean by
essence
have you ever been around a dog that
gets wet and they shake
and then there gets all over you that to
me is the definition of essence
so you walk into a room what is it
that shakes off onto other people what's
the word right here
excited anyone else determined
kind energy back in the back just shout
out
thoughtful love sexy
awesome so it was interesting because
the word that fell
out because i immediately thought i
wonder if mine is confidence and then i
thought well wait a minute actually no
it's try
all i want you to ever do is try
that's it i just want you to try in
those moments where
you hear yourself i want you to try in
those moments where you know
that it's time to speak up i want you to
try that's all that i
ever ask of you because if you simply do
that
and i say simply as if it's so easy
right
you will literally unlock the potential
of your life
here's another massive insight so i
always think about businesses levels
right
and i also realize that as the media
landscape
or the um the particular vertical
or industry that you're building a
business in is changing
that is a constant and it's something
that you can't control right you just
cannot control the things that are
happening in the world around us
but you can always control what you're
thinking
and what you're doing in response to it
so all of my work
centers inside this gap between what's
happening
in your life and in your work and what
your reaction is to it and how you can't
control
the things that are going on around you
but you can always control
what your reaction is and that gap there
that's about five seconds long
and you start to understand that you can
change how you think you can change your
habits you can change how you
lead you can pivot and change even the
philosophy
of your company and you can do it
through the decisions that you're making
and managing your reactions
you will become unstoppable so three
years three and a half years ago i got
into the speaking business
um because of the popularity of that
tedx talk that i gave
and um that first year i did
um i don't know i think was like 27
speeches the next year
i did 87 last year i did 121 i was the
most booked female speaker in the world
this year i've kept it at 80 and here's
why i realize
just like you may be realizing in your
business whatever your business is
that there are aspects of your business
that you love and that energize you and
there are aspects of your business that
are depleting as hell
and that are old and that are tired and
that if you continue
in that lane you're going to end up 10
years from now
in a place that you don't want to be
it's so important for you to pay
attention to what's energizing you about
the landscape around you
and about your own business because
that's the secret to seeing around
corners
and so the corner that i was seeing
around is that as an entrepreneur
even though it's wildly lucrative to do
what i do just on the speaking platform
i mean anybody can do the math on 121
speeches right and the amount of money
that i get paid to show up and deliver a
one-hour talk
and realize there's a lot of money
here's the problem it's a terrible
business because you can't scale it
other than raising your price
or raising the number of times you do it
and guess what else
you have to show up and i can't sell it
so i found myself in a situation where i
had built
a multi-million dollar business
highly profitable and it was depleting
the academy
and i can't really scale it and i can't
sell it
terrible opposition to be in in an
entrepreneur
so i made a decision that i you know
what was it bo
that actually energizes me about my
business and i answered it with the
first question
it's hearing from people i would rather
answer comments on instagram all day
long
than stand in a stadium with 5 000
people in it
i get more from the one to one
connection
that's what fuels me and so i had this
light bulb moment paying
attention being clear that wait a minute
i don't want to build
the biggest speaking platform and i
don't want to build a coaching business
i want to build a content company i want
to go back to my roots and build a
media company and so with that
insight i now have to change right
because the kind of
business woman that runs a
multi-multi-million dollar
speaking business where it's just you
and your speaking management firm
and your travel folks and your logistics
people
and maybe your social media manager
that's who's on the team
the kind of leader that runs that kind
of team is very different
than the kind of leader that is going to
grow a hundred million dollar
media company that's going to syndicate
content
every single day that is going to own
what she's doing that's going to build
instagram and facebook and youtube and
linkedin as my
personal abc cnbc fox
and this is what i want you to
understand about the story
and that is this in order to get to the
next level in your business you got to
decide right now
what habits do you have as a leader
that you have to change now because you
will not see around the corner you will
not
engineer that next quantum leap unless
you personally change
and so one of the reasons why i've gone
from being
the most successful female you know book
speaker
on the speaking circuit to launching the
number one
book on all of the self-publishing
platform
for amazon and one of the most read
books in the world
and selling like gangbusters still
is because i am constantly innovating
myself
i know that i am the single biggest
problem in my company and if i
don't constantly pivot and evolve
how i lead and what i'm focused on
i'm gonna be the blockade and so you
know stop looking at
what everybody else is doing stop
micromanaging the team
and ask yourself two years from now
when you think about where you want your
company to be
what habit do you have to change right
now do you think it's a fear of being
uncomfortable or failure that's really
like the barrier for people
the barrier is everybody gives what
other people
[Music]
uh we are going to the country hall
music
the country hall of fame um
no i am not singing everyone should
thank
whomever they pray to that i'm not
thinking singing
um for a big conference and so we're
about to do a keynote to a couple
thousand people
and then do a q a and i'm excited i'll
see you all upstairs
do you think it's a fear of being
uncomfortable or failure that's really
like the barrier for people
the barrier is everybody gives a [ __ ]
what other people are thinking
yeah and so they're on camera or they're
on a microphone
trying to be smart or concerned about
whether or not they look good in the
shot uh
concerned about uh how they sound
whether or not they started
if their neck is turning red like
whatever it may be
and they're so up here that they're not
actually being true to just saying
what's right here
absolutely whether you're speaking from
the heart speaking from the gut like
that is the skill to develop
is the ability to be more like an 11
year old
that gets on camera and can just be
themselves
instead of being a 49 year old person
censoring themselves
and that's what i'm talking about when i
talk about the truth when i talk about
authenticity
that people really want to feel that
connection
and the only way that they're going to
feel that connection is if you
do the work to remove the own veneer and
the
own barriers that you put in between you
and other people
and the number one thing is everybody
gives too much of a [ __ ]
about what everybody else thinks and you
know who they think the
they're worried the most about their
friends if i
put this thing up not for my friends but
for the people that i'm trying to build
a rapport with online my friends are
going to judge me
your friends seriously if you're out to
make a difference if you're out to share
something that is important to you
if your friends don't like it or don't
support you they're really not your
friends
it really works as action because if
you're stopping to think
about what people are thinking or
whether or not you're worried about
what people are thinking you've already
fallen into the trap
the second that you push yourself to get
started through the action
itself you are proving to yourself that
even though you care what everybody
thinks
you're going to do it anyway let me tell
you something a big mistake that we make
as entrepreneurs is we think that we've
got to build
everything ourselves and what's super
cool about business today
is that there are channels where you can
make money
so that you don't have to do things that
are outside your core
expertise you're a photographer you're
amazing at it you're a networker i can
already tell you're amazing at it what
you should never
ever do is spend time building a stock
photography
site because that is not your core
capability
but if you just focus on taking photos
which you love and
you upload the stuff that you're not
going to monetize some other way to a
stock photography
site as long as it's not other you know
it's not as long as you know you've got
the rights to it and everything else
you can make money on that stuff all day
long and in fact because so many people
are creating content the stock
photography sites have exploded it's not
just
getty and stock list and some of the
other ones that a ton of people use
there are there are tons of them out
there and so that's one thing that you
should be doing okay where else do you
want to grow your business
i want to make sure i'm able to do that
first step
very well before i progress on to the to
the next phase
okay i don't want to do so many
different things that i'm not doing
each one of them very well that's right
so anything where you're going to have
to learn a new skill and somebody else
has done it and you can outsource it
just like uploading to stock sites that
is you don't want to make the mistake of
having your attention go
off the ball which is creating a big
library of photos
and building something that you have no
interest in building a year ago
february 28th i believe it was we
launched the five second rule book
and there are so many lessons
in not only the launch of that book and
how i did it as a business woman but
also the trajectory
that has happened since then number one
it's important for you to know that
um it was one of the
top five most read books on amazon last
year it was the number one
audiobook in the world it is the number
one selling
title on amazon and audible
self-publishing
audible platform that's really cool
because
as an entrepreneur for me personally
it's so
important for me to kind to have control
of the work that i'm doing
that decision to self-publish has paid
off
more than it's paid off financially and
it certainly will pay you more
in the long tail financially when you
own your work and when you self-publish
and if you have an idea that you have
been thinking about and you're watching
beau's show
and you're watching evan's channel to
get the motivation
to continue to tell your story to do the
work to get your stuff
out there the one thing i'll say is if
you believe in what you're doing
don't sell it to somebody self-publish
it
because you will eventually it might not
happen in the first year but eventually
your work will bump into the right
audience and it will grow and it will
grow
and you will really regret having sold
for pennies on the dollar
the thing that was really your life's
work and so please please please if
you're
a content generator if you're an
entrepreneur if you're a writer
if you're a song producer own what
you're doing at least in the beginning
until you start to understand the
industry
and the economics of things if you're
trying to stop yourself from
repeating a pattern of behavior let's
use drinking okay
if you're trying to use it to stop
yourself from drinking
and you feel yourself being drawn to go
pour the glass of wine because it's six
o'clock right
and you got home and it's time to have
that glass of wine and by the way time
of day is a huge trigger for behaviors
huge trigger so you feel yourself being
drawn toward the glass of wine go
five four three two one and physically
move away from it so that's one thing
that you can do
in terms of the thoughts and we go into
this in depth
in the five second rule book there's
some science around something called
if then planning so if then planning
will make you
60 more likely to stick to a commitment
and what if then planning is is it is
coming up with a plan b
before the you know what hits the fan
and so
in the case of thinking patterns that
are negative
or behavior patterns like pleasing
people or silencing yourself
what i want you to do is it can be very
effective to write down
all the times where you're typically
triggered to do that
or to think that negative thing then
come up
with what you're going to do instead
ahead of time
if this person uses that tone of voice
with me and speaks in a different
disrespectful way instead of standing
here and taking it
five four three two one then i'm gonna
do this
i am a productivity consultant i've had
a challenge with people
they know what they need to do and this
is my challenge as well i know what i
need to do i know it needs to be done
right getting that motivation and
getting over that ledge
and that five second rule my goodness
changed my life i haven't quite made it
to not hitting snooze yet
okay why oh because my bed feels so
comfy in the morning
let me tell you something okay are you
ready i'm ready
your business will go to the next level
the second
you actually beat the habit of hitting
the snooze
and the reason why is because
of the science around productivity
and the brain okay and when you push
yourself
to walk the talk and have the first 30
minutes
of your day be the most productive for
your brain
you will bring a level of conviction
and authority and impact to
the business that's not there currently
right
you see when you're uh an expert and
you're
a consultant your power is limited
to the extent that you personally feel
like you're not using the tools does
that make sense that makes sense i say
this
for myself i say this because
when i think about businesses that i've
had in the past or when i was an
executive coach
and i would be giving advice but i'm not
technically following it in the same
regard
i'm not as powerful right and so i would
highly highly highly
encourage you starting tomorrow morning
you want to be the best productivity
coach on the planet that alarm goes off
notice the gap right because the more
that you start to play
with this five second window and you go
five four three two one and you push
yourself out of bed and you hate it
and then you take your cold shower and
you hate it and then you don't look at
your phone and you hate it and then you
spend the first 30 minutes of the day
pushing
something forward and you hate it but
you do it
you will now be able to coach people who
do the exact same thing right
you're never ever ever ever going to
feel like doing the things you need to
do
in order to have what you want you're
always going to need to push yourself
you're
always going to need to parent yourself
so
what is the net advice on this what what
is the bottom line
the bottom line is no one's coming
no one no one's coming to push you
no one's coming to tell you to turn the
tv off no one's coming to tell you to
get out the door and exercise
nobody's coming to tell you to apply for
that
job that you've always dreamt about
nobody's coming to write the business
plan for you
it's up to you and because you're
only ever going to do the things that
you feel like doing right now or that
feel
good right now unless you understand
that you've got to parent yourself you
got to push yourself
you're not going to make your dreams
come true you're just not
we're not wired that way you weren't
born that way you weren't that way when
you were growing up and you're certainly
not that way as an adult
and there's a tremendous amount of
liberation that comes when you accept
the fact
that you're always going to need to give
yourself a push
i want to talk to those of you that are
working toward your dreams
whatever it is that you're doing right
now it's leading
to the thing that you dream of doing
and you're not going to progress until
you
get the skills and the experience that
you need
at the level that you're at i guarantee
you even if you're working
at a front desk
job at a local gym you're learning
customer
service you need to learn that kind of
stuff before you can launch your own
business
for me in order to be an incredible
speaker that can command a stage with 3
000 people in the audience for an entire
hour i first had to learn how to have
the courage to speak up and have hard
conversations in my life
then i had to learn how to speak up in a
small meeting then i had to learn how to
speak
up uh you know in a church basement then
i had to learn how to
give a little bit of a talk at a brown
bag luncheon then i had to learn
how to stand on a slightly bigger stage
so
if you're frustrated with where you are
right now because you've got these big
dreams and you think you're really far
away
here's one way that you can continue to
be patient and you can
milk wherever you're at to help you
build the skills and the experience that
you need
as you climb toward the thing that you
want ask yourself
what is it that i am learning what's the
skill that i'm
honing by sitting here at this front
desk job or driving
this uber or lyft vehicle what am i
learning that i'm going to take with me
on my journey to do that next big thing
because i guarantee you there's
something
in the minutia of what you're doing
right now that you are developing an
expertise and a skill around
that you're going to need as you launch
yourself towards the next thing
so here's what you're going to do it's
actually simple but it's not going to be
easy because you're going to create all
kinds of excuses and drama for yourself
okay
you're going to set your alarm for 7.
and when the alarm goes off that's what
happened
that gap is going to open up and you're
going to feel all rolling i don't feel
like it i'm
over i don't want to i don't feel like
writing a song anyway
you know like that's when you have to
take control you have to take control
you have to get up every morning it
begins by getting up because if you let
anxiety excuses self-doubt all the
win in that first decision the rest of
the day is hijacked so win the first
decision
then exercise i don't care about the
eating as much
i know it's important not to put garbage
in but i would rather
see you first master getting up on time
do that for a week then let's add
in exercise every day 10 minutes don't
start with like two hours because then
you're gonna find an excuse not to do it
get up at seven
exercise for ten minutes then the third
week you're gonna add in like i'm
actually gonna eat clean this week or
whatever
the diet is that you wanna eat right
you're just gonna add in things as you
master the little things
but you gotta get up on time it starts
right there you know we all
face problems in our lives it's just
part of being a human being
but have you ever considered that there
are really only two
kinds of problems that you're ever going
to face there are temporary problems
and then there are permanent problems
that are more like
conditions that you have to learn with
now a temporary problem is something
that you have
tremendous power to change and permanent
problems though
are something that require a different
skill and that is the ability to just
accept things as they are and let the
complaining go
now one of the skills in life that is
really going to help you become a great
problem solver and it's also going to
give you more control
over your life is knowing what kind of
problem you're actually dealing with
because we all complain about our
problems
but to actually solve a problem you got
to understand
what kind of problem you're dealing with
the truth is you can't
change a permanent problem so no matter
how much you complain about it
how much you try to change it how much
energy you put into it
nothing's changing it's a waste of your
time and your energy to focus on those
when you try to change a permanent
problem you know you
are stuck because you feel like you're
just spinning in circles
temporary problems are what you want to
focus your energy on
these are the decisions and the life
choices that you keep making
that might feel good in the moment but
they actually make you miserable
now here's the thing about temporary
problems they're not permanent
you may hate your body but you can
change it
you may hate and be unhappy in the
relationship that you're in
but you can change it you might complain
a lot about how your boss treats you or
how you feel passed over at work
but you can change how you interact with
your boss and you can change how you
show up at work and you can even change
your job
that's the difference between a
temporary and a permanent problem
temporary problems you can change now
here's a
simple exercise that i want you to do i
want you to make a list of
all the things that you complain about
maybe you complain about your commute
where you live the person you're with
your health
your boss the amount of money you have
now i want you to look
at every single complaint you have and
ask yourself
what can i do to change this problem
what can i do to fix my relationship
with your boss because you can't change
your boss's personality
but you can definitely change how you
interact with her
and when you change yourself and your
own behaviors
and how you think you're going to change
everything
i've always been very scared
and lack of confidence
and thought that i was never good enough
like some of my partners
we've all bought into a lie we've bought
into a lie that confidence is belief in
self
and so when you're in a situation which
is normal where you don't believe in
yourself you're like oh my god i have no
confidence
the truth is and i want you to walk out
of here with a new definition of
confidence
confidence is the willingness to try
because when you try
and you take action what happens and
what's happened for france
is that when she sees herself
taking action what happens is she
sees herself being the kind of person
that takes action so she has evidence
that she can rely on herself and that
action
is what builds confidence it doesn't
start with belief
the real way the real way for most of us
is not to wait to believe but to push
ourselves to act and through the action
you will build the belief
so let's pretend that this right here
this empty mason jar is your brain
in order to do your best thinking you
need to make sure that you've got the
full capacity of your brain
leveraged and pointed at the things that
are important to you here's the problem
when you go through life as you go
through life what happens
is you know your brain starts to fill up
with information and that's what creates
a state of feeling overwhelmed
being overwhelmed is nothing more than
having a full brain so as you go through
your day-to-day life and you start
checking email and looking at texts and
looking at facebook and sitting in
meetings and flipping through television
channels and
sending uh emails and writing excel
spreadsheets
and running and picking up the kids at
work and
getting another text and looking at
instagram and looking at twitter and
checking out the news your brain gets
pretty full doesn't it
and so when you feel overwhelmed what i
know about you is that your brain is
full of a bunch of garbage
and so oh i didn't think about the drain
draining i hope that's not bothering you
but it's certainly going to bother me
what you need to do in order to fight
overwhelm is you've got to actually do a
brain dump
you got to get rid of all that stuff so
that you've got an empty brain
so you can focus again so how do you do
that it's easy to do with a cup of water
because you just pour it out
this is what you're gonna do you are
literally going to dump out
everything that's in your head onto this
piece of paper every concern
every worry every to-do every thing
that's bothering you
that you're thinking about you're going
to write down
[Music]
all right and when you're done writing
down everything that's in your head and
there's absolutely nothing left oh
i've got something due tomorrow that i
kind of forgot about um once you get
that stuff all done on a piece of paper
pull out a highlighter take a look
you could do everything on this list you
could
but what should you do what are three
things
just three that you should do in order
to advance the things that matter to you
let's see i gotta do that one i gotta do
that one
and i gotta do that one the rest of this
list
is complete and other garbage it's other
people's stuff it's the email stuff it's
the meeting stuff it's the
stuff that's not all that important to
me it's not that mission critical
so by dumping everything out i now not
only have the three things i need to do
i've got a clear head so i can get it
done if you're about to
do something for the first time chances
are high that you might embarrass
yourself but what it means is if you're
willing to be the kind of person
that is willing to embarrass themselves
it means you're trying something new
it means you're going for it when
everybody else sits on the sidelines
and so one of the things that i would
encourage you to do
is that when you feel that tingling like
you're starting to hold yourself back
because you start thinking about what
all your friends
are thinking about that's a moment to go
oh this is what that lady was talking
about 54321
i'm going for it you're not a
procrastinator
you have a habit of procrastinating
big difference because if it's a habit
i can teach you to use science to break
it you see all habits have three parts
there's a trigger
and in the case of procrastination the
trigger's always stress
then there's a pattern you repeat and in
the case of procrastination
it is to avoid doing something
and then there's a reward you get a
little stress relief
the only way to break a habit you guys
is not to deal with the triggers you're
never going to get rid of the stress in
your life
but you can 100 change your pattern of
avoiding
work so next time that you're in a
situation where you feel yourself
hesitate
you spent way too much time checking out
the highlights from last night's scores
what you're going to do is you're going
to go oh i must be stressed out about
something
acknowledge the stress then go five four
three two one i want you to count to
yourself because i want you to interrupt
the habit that's stored here
and i want you to awaken your prefrontal
cortex then i want you to just work
just for five minutes the reason why i
want you to only work for five minutes
is because your problem isn't working
it's the habit of avoiding i just need
you to start and here's the other cool
thing
we know based on research that if we can
get you to start
80 percent of you are going to keep
going if
your friend is facing a problem when you
have to make decisions
on behalf of your friend you tend to
think from multiple perspectives you
think about multiple outcomes and
ultimately you make a much better
decision what they found in research
though is if they put you
in the exact same situation facing the
exact same thing that your friend is
you're not able to be so objective
because you're emotional
and you don't make that great a decision
what's the conclusion well when you make
decisions for other people you're great
when we make decisions for ourselves
decisions that can be emotional we're
not so good at it that's where the power
of objectivity comes in
it's the ability to make a decision from
a third
party's perspective let me explain so if
you're facing
a really important decision and you can
feel yourself getting emotional maybe
you're thinking about
asking for a raise or changing your
career or changing your major
or ending a relationship or starting a
relationship whatever it may be if it's
something that is emotional for you
you're going to have a hard time
thinking about all the options and
you're going to be really attached
emotionally because
maybe you're concerned about the people
who may be impacted by your decision
maybe you're managing that somebody's
going to be disappointed or
hurt by what you need to do for you this
is when the power of objectivity is
really
important pick somebody that you really
admire i mean it could be
somebody like a bill gates or richard
branson or an oprah winfrey or
maybe have a mentor and stop yourself
and ask what would oprah do in this
situation
what would richard branson do in this
situation what would your mentor do in
this situation
bringing that level of third-party
objectivity will yank
you out of your body and your emotions
and it will help you
give yourself the perspective that you
need and the distance from your emotions
so that you can actually assess
your options and make the best decision
for you
what would mel do if mel were making the
decision the best decision you know
there's a really interesting example
of somebody who did this in sports and
at the time
he actually got a lot of flack for it it
was lebron james
now lebron james as you know played for
the cleveland cavaliers for a really
really long time
and he's arguably one of the best
basketball players to ever hit the nba
so he made this announcement that he was
going to leave the cleveland cavaliers
where he had been playing forever had
rabid rabid fans and he was going to
leave them and go to miami
miami that was the conclusion you woke
up with this morning
that was the conclusion i woke up with
this morning he was giving an interview
to espn
and what he said was this he said lebron
james
needs to do what's best for lebron james
now people kind of laughed at him
because it's a funny way to say the
sentence
but this guy is really smart he was
leveraging the power of objectivity
mel robbins needs to learn how to do
what's best for mel robbins
and you need to learn how to do what's
best for you the thing that i'm stuck on
is that i have a bazillion ideas
about things that i can create and do
and courses and
trainings and la da da who can relate
and so
actually moving from the idea and
even creating the whole curriculum and
all of that to actually making it happen
yeah and doing it so i have a cool
strategy that i use and i hope it works
for you so i carry
a little notebook and i actually
borrowed this from chris because when we
lived in new york city he used to carry
around a notebook like this size and
whenever
he had an idea he'd just jot it down
then he'd stick it in his back pocket
and he was just full of all kinds of
stuff so i carry around a notebook and
this one's new so it doesn't really have
much in it
as ideas come i just jot it down in that
notebook
and then what happens for me is i get
anxiety
because i'm afraid that i'm going to
forget the idea
then that anxiety makes me get
distracted
and unfocused and overwhelmed and
so i think if you were to have a little
notebook on you at all times
and when those creative juices and those
impulses go
that you jot them down that's going to
remove
one layer of the overwhelm i think you
should chase
what energizes you everyone talks about
passion legacy purpose
the one word to pay attention to is
energy i love that
that's it let's simplify this okay so
whatever energizes you naturally
expands you feels like possibility is
exciting to do
it may be scary that doesn't matter it
has to do with how it makes you feel
right when you were in your 20s money
made you feel good
it expanded you it energized you chasing
the money
that was the game that was your passion
that was your there's nothing
wrong with that nothing wrong with that
and i particularly want to say that to
the women that are watching yeah
because it is socialized into women not
to chase success like that
not to go after the money and so if
what energizes you is amassing wealth
go for it but what hap and and the
reason why i say that is because people
talk about the word passion yeah or
purpose right
and the truth is it's not a person place
or a thing
it's not it is
the feeling of being
expanded and energized right if you're
pursuing your passion
it means that you wake up every day and
are energized
so instead of trying to think what's my
purpose what's my passion what's my
purpose what's my passion
instead of thinking like that i want you
instead to ask yourself
what's what could i do today that would
energize me
what energizes me if it's making money
figure out how to make money right if it
is
making a difference figure out how to
make a difference
it could be in any single shape or form
but if it energizes you that's what you
need to follow
and what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time
because when you first start making
money it's thrilling
yeah thrilling there is nothing more
exhilarating than making your first
million yeah
nothing more exhilarating but what
happens is once you learn how to do
something once
you can do it over and over again and so
it starts to become routine
yeah which means it's no longer
energizing right which is why
every entrepreneur out there goes
through the mode of chasing the money
and then you hit
the money that you need to make then
you're like i'm not fulfilled yeah
i don't have to do it yeah i went
through that you finally you know i did
everybody yes yeah and it's because you
were energized by the money
and now you're not yeah now you got to
be energized
by the next thing it turns out that one
of the best
stress relievers on the planet is
something that most of us don't ever do
and that is seek out time with friends
when we feel totally stressed out
when you're doing twice as much work as
you normally do or you're feeling
twice as much stress as you normally
feel studies at harvard
show that what you need is you need to
see your friends twice as much
now shawn anchor is a really famous
researcher and best-selling author at
harvard and
he studied this phenomenon he looked at
at people that were stressed at schools
and in call centers and in the military
and in banks and in
almost every single industry what he
discovered is that the most successful
people the people that were the best at
selling the people that they were the
most resilient the people that had the
best
ability to deal with stress when times
got tough
were the ones that saw their friends the
most it was the people with the tightest
social connections that have the ability
to weather the storms that life throw at
us
i want you to write down three people
three people that when you hang out with
them you feel
energized that when you have plans with
them you're excited about seeing
them when this video ends reach out to
them
that's right pick up the phone send them
a text i want you to invite them to do
something
go out to lunch go for a walk in the
woods get a cup of coffee go out to
dinner
even if you're not stressed out i
guarantee you at least one of the three
people that you're gonna reach out to
needs you
when i'm with cooler or popular guys i
feel inferior and worthless which
affects me and weirdly i try so hard to
impress them and be like them
like a chameleon i try to avoid them but
i feel left out
whatever i do i feel sad or useless what
can i do in order to overcome this
you don't have to hang out with people
you don't like there's a pro
life tip for everybody you don't have to
one of the things
that is a massive indication that you're
hanging out with the wrong group of
people
is that you don't feel comfortable being
yourself the second
you try to be somebody else or you feel
like a chameleon just to fit in
you are trying to fit in with the wrong
group relationships only work
when you can be the real you people
thrive on energy that's what drives
connection
you're with people that make you wither
and hide and feel insecure
you are with the wrong people you need
to find your people
and your people are the kind of people
that the second you hang out with them
you don't feel like less of yourself you
feel like more of yourself
you don't feel like you gotta hide or be
somebody else you feel like you want to
express yourself
and show up and be more of yourself to
address what happened
you can now have the self-awareness
to create a new story to start a new
chapter to see the old strategy
and now consciously you talk about
consciously creating
consciously create a different response
that's what i do for people
i am helping people identify the
internal conflicts that are making them
miserable
that are ruining the relationships that
are destroying their self-esteem
and then once we highlight those we pick
a different
strategy right that's what we do and
you know anybody can do it today for the
next 24 hours i want you to assume
that everybody else around you has the
best intentions
the person that cuts you off in traffic
the friend that's not texting you back
the customer that writes an email that
has a snarky tone
whatever it may be the fact that you may
be riled that you posted something on
facebook and
and one of your best friends didn't tag
you in it or didn't like it i mean we
get
hung up around the stuff but today i
want you to assume
the best intentions you know this
recently happened to me where i really
had to put this to use
i had a situation at work where i had a
conference call and it was related to a
speech and
it was one of these kind of kickoff
calls where a bunch of people on the
client side are going to be there and
we're going to talk about the event and
i'm going to talk about the speech and
during the conversation this conference
call
i said something that i didn't mean to
say i was totally responsible i
basically said
what day am i speaking now i knew the
date that i was speaking
what i didn't know is in the flow of the
event
was i the opener was i the closer was i
the person that's supposed to be the
defibrillator after a big lunch like
what role
am i playing that's a really important
thing to understand if you're giving a
speech because it helps you customize
what you're going to do well the client
misunderstood
me because i wasn't precise and they
were annoyed
because they thought holy cow we've
we've hired this person we've sent her
all kinds of information she doesn't
even know what day she's speaking
so the client gets upset they complain
to the event planner
the event planner then writes me one of
these emails that's like this long
the planner was really upset because i
had made
the planner look bad in front of the
client
now fully my responsibility completely
unintentional
and also based on a gigantic
misunderstanding so what did i do well i
did exactly what you should do when you
screw up i took
total responsibility i apologized i went
overboard and
cleaned the mess up i wrote a long email
i actually left voicemail messages
when we had to deliver a bunch of things
i went overboard and being great about
it and you know what i got from
the planner that was really upset with
me nothing
i didn't get an email back i didn't get
a phone call back
even though i had requested one nothing
nothing nothing nothing and of course
what happens when somebody
doesn't respond to you whether it's
somebody that you're dating or it's
somebody that's a good friend
or it's a customer or somebody that's
upset with you and you've apologized
you immediately think that you've done
something wrong
we even do it if you get an email and
somebody's tone is slightly off it is
bananas how quickly we assume male
intent we assume we're in trouble we
assume we've done something wrong
so what did i do in this situation
because my reaction was i was
disappointed that i didn't
actually get a nice email back or hey no
problem let's move on and have a great
event just got silenced what did i do
i use the five second rule five four
three two one when i catch myself
thinking about it and then i assume
positive intent i tell myself a
different story i say oh
well i've apologized twice so maybe the
planner feels
that everything is complete and taken
care of and no need to discuss it
further i also assume hey
this event is a big event i'm sure
they're super duper busy and this is the
last concern on their list another thing
that you can say is
maybe they're busy maybe this isn't a
big deal to them
maybe i've already been forgiven
oh great so excellent i hope she learned
something you're never going to feel
ready to speak up okay and for the girl
for
girls in particular super important
visibility
you don't get credit for things people
don't see and so
raising your voice and learning how to
do it in a classroom before you get into
the workforce before you got to raise
money
so important and so what i want you to
know is
you're never if you're somebody who's
like
introverted or somewhat shy you're never
going to feel comfortable doing it
but you've got to do it your dreams
depend on it what happens in your body
when you're about to raise your hand
okay and what does it feel like in your
body
okay is your stomach hurt or is your
throat tight yeah does your chest get a
rash like mine used to
oh see you're lucky okay what about your
hands do they get clammy
yeah okay so the main thing to do is
when that happens
just go oh that's a thing that was
talking about
my body's getting ready to talk so
before i
give a speech i give about 100 speeches
a year do you know what happens in my
body
my stomach hurts my armpits are like
niagara falls
my hands are clammy my throat is tight
and i feel like i'm going to throw up do
you think i'm nervous
exactly my body is getting in a state
to do something that's why nerves and
excitement are the exact same so the
next time you're in a class or you're
with a group of friends and there's
something you want to say
tell me what happens again in your body
your stomach starts to hurt what does it
mean
yes what does it mean on a positive side
yes you're getting ready to talk i love
that so that's the way that we are going
to
re-uh label that tape in your mind
my stomach's in knots okay i'm not
nervous i'm getting ready to talk here
we go that's that signal mel robin said
she gets it in the stadium i'm getting
it right now
five four three two one i'm going okay
any decision
can be dif divided into
what do i need to do
versus how and when do i need to do it
for the what that is intuition and
by intuition i use the word energy
and the way to answer any question
for yourself personally that you don't
immediately know the answer to
is to ask this question does it
energize and expand my life or does it
shrink it
if it energizes and expands your life
the answer is
yes you should absolutely do it that is
what you should do
if the decision shrinks you
or it deflates you then the answer is
no you should not do it this is an
incredible tool to use in deal making
by the way because uh you know i'm in
the middle of negotiating a
massive media deal at the moment and
it's something i've always wanted to do
yeah
and um when you're negotiating for
something you really want whether it's
somebody that you're dating or
you know it's a salary or whatever in my
case it's a massive media deal
you can get really ego driven right
right you can start to get very attached
to the deal
or to the person or to the whatever
but you have to stop and ask yourself is
this
deal or this person actually expanding
right and energizing are or
are there aspects of it that deplete and
shrink me
and if there's any aspect of it that
depletes and shrinks
you either have to change that aspect of
the deal or the relationship structure
or you have to say no period right
if you decide that yeah it energizes me
and i really want to do it then that's
what you want
next you've got to think about the
outcome which is
how and when you make it happen right
have you ever heard the term
attention economy if you haven't heard
it you're going to start hearing it a
lot
because that's what we live in right now
it means that people
and companies make money when they have
your attention
and in the world of internet technology
social media
your attention is for sale and what i
want to do in today's mentoring session
is i want to shift
your attitude about how you value your
own
attention so got a simple question for
you do you
use a phone or a computer to make money
or to improve your life or does the
phone use
you to make money oh look at this
i lifted it up and it started playing a
video check it out
it's on facebook right now every time
you are on your laptop and you go onto a
laptop and you start scrolling
mindlessly through facebook
someone else is making money you ever
thought about that like i'm gonna just
scroll through facebook right now oh
here's a post about yoga tights i don't
need oh and here's something from
buzzfeed about cute group photo of 23
baby pandas trying to make
you know who's making money right now
whoever made this video
and so is buzzfeed and so is facebook
but i'm not
they're making money off my attention
and as i keep scrolling oh here's
somebody that's doing something related
to the news and
here's another thing ooh chocolate chip
peanut butter cup lasagna cake
am i making money am i improving my life
by
no but guess what tasty video is
and so is melissa's southern style
kitchen who sponsored this post
so why am i pointing this out to you i'm
pointing it out to you because the
engineers at facebook
the engineers at every website they they
understand something
they understand that the longer that you
spend on their website or reading their
emails or clicking their stuff
the more money they're going to make see
you and i are up against
a massive amount of technology and
people that want
to trick us into giving them our
attention
there's a reason why facebook has an
algorithm where they put
things in your news feed that you like
it's because research
shows that you'll actually stay longer
and how does somebody make money
in the attention economy well they make
it by grabbing your attention
so i want you to consider something
today i want you to be
really mindful about your attention i
want you to be mindful about
how you're using your phone and your
computer
are you using it to get ahead and to
make more money
and to do the things that are important
to you or are they using you
to make a buck as you're going about
your day
just notice am i picking up my phone to
use it to improve my life
or make my goals happen or am i picking
up my phone and letting somebody
else use me to make money you said into
the microphone
that you think you're not good enough so
how does thinking that you're not
good enough stop you from taking the
action you need to take
i haven't embraced technology okay
now we're somewhere okay okay
i now know and i know why i know why
the reason why is because it's not that
you don't think you're good enough
you don't think you're smart i'm an
atron man
and the the thing that's underneath i'm
not good enough is you actually believe
you're not smart enough
and so you avoid the things that scare
you
and you have a very you have a fabulous
personality
i love that you're making jokes about
the fact that you're an eight-track man
but the reason why and i do the same
thing i make jokes about this i don't
want to deal with either
because it's easier it is scary to say
i don't know how to do this and i'm
scared if i actually pivot and start
focusing on technology because i need to
then i'm not going to know how and so
it's easier to be busy
and it's easier to be on television
stations and it's easier to try to
do all this stuff that feels good
because it's in my wheelhouse we all
do it and so what i want you to really
take a look at
is where does my story that i'm not
smart
where is it blocking my dream where is
it
lying to me because you are smart and
here's the other thing you don't have to
be smart you have to work hard
and you work very hard and you are very
committed but there are things that you
know you know how many are you relating
to this conversation
look around you are not alone
there are things that you know that you
must
focus on but it scares you because it
triggers that button than you i just got
a phd that's it i hope they don't find
out i don't know what the hell i'm doing
oh
god oh my god how do i know this is what
you're thinking because this is what i
think
i want you to look at where in your life
that story
is robbing you of your dreams and where
it is giving you an
excuse to avoid the things that you know
you need to do
okay what did you just get from our
conversation i
i got that i need to uh meditate and see
exactly
why am i not taking action and start you
know doing it
and embracing it and i'm good enough i'm
more than enough
i love vision boards and gratitude
journaling because they help me think
about what i want and why
this journal it's going to teach you how
how you make your dreams come true i
created this journaling method a couple
years ago because i wanted to stop
thinking about what i wanted and
actually make it happen this is simple
it's backed by science and it's going to
help you make your dreams come true with
just a couple minutes every morning let
me show you how it works
at the very top you write down the time
place and date this simple trick gets
you present and grounded in the moment
now notice
this is guilt-free journaling there are
no dates printed so if you miss a day or
two
you're not behind next i'm gonna give
you a superpower
this my friend is your inner compass
learning to read your energy
is the secret to greater passion
productivity and living with more
purpose
research from the university of
pennsylvania proves that if you boost
your mood in the morning
you actually increase your productivity
all day long these next two questions
will help you take control of your
energy
which changes how your mind perceives
tasks and will make you more confident
about the day ahead
and this section right here it's the
secret to having a great day
i want you to identify one project that
matters to you today
not two not three just one when you
focus on just
one project a day you leverage the
progress principle it was invented at
the harvard business school and it will
change your life and help you
be more productive so you can make your
dreams come true research proves you get
more done when you focus on less
and every day i want you to focus on
just one thing
after you write down your top project i
want you to write down why this project
matters to you
when you know your why science says
you're going to be more inspired and
motivated to get it done
now take that vision and make it your
mission write down
one small action that you're going to
take today to move your dream forward
it doesn't matter how small it is
forward is forward according to research
simply using this section of the journal
makes you 76
more likely to go from dreaming to doing
and if you have any other thoughts about
the project here's some extra space to
play around with
when you move from thinking to doing it
may make you feel overwhelmed so let's
change that attitude with a little
gratitude
studies prove that grounding yourself in
something that you feel grateful for
will boost your happiness and your
effectiveness finally
i want you to write down your quitting
time yup you heard me right
part of your morning routine should be
deciding when you're gonna stop working
at night
if you feel like your wheels are
spinning and you don't get anything done
if you have no balance between work and
life
if you'd love to spend more time with
your family and still feel like the most
productive person you know
set a quitting time this is called
parkinson's law
and it's rocket feel for your
productivity now let's go over to the
next page
everyone works differently so this page
is designed to work for you
if you love making long to-do lists and
checking things off here's the spot
if you want to plan out your day there's
a timeline on the left and if you need a
place to take notes
here's a place where you put them so
there you have it the five second
journal
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated but never created a plan
and when you share your plan and have
accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through
so in the comments below write down your
single biggest takeaway as well as your
specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
part of the self-awareness
and self-mastery and the ability to move
your life forward is not only
in 5-4-3-2-1 finding the instant
motivation
and courage to push yourself forward but
the true liberation and freedom is going
to come when you start to understand
the body signals that got programmed a
long time ago
long time ago in your body that are
holding you back
and learning how in those moments when
you get a pit in your stomach to
recognize it
and slow the body sensations down and
then move forward
before your mind starts talking you out
of it so a lot of what happens for us
is you had situations when you were a
kid maybe
your mom or your dad were really intense
maybe you grew up in a very
competitive household maybe you
um were the kind of kid that things were
better in your house when you were seen
but not heard
and so any and your body remembers it
your body remembers situations when your
parents were yelling because as a kid it
feels traumatic
your body remembers situations were in a
classroom you were nervous or afraid to
be called out or be seen
your body remembers moments when you
were embarrassed and so what's
interesting is that
um your body
will now face any situation where you're
about to be seen
or you're about to speak up or you're
about to do something where you're
facing uncertainty
or you're about to um
face judgment and your body remembers
those situations and it starts to get
nervous or agitated or on edge because
it knows oh my god you're about to do
something that's going to expose you and
your body wants to keep you safe
that's why your stomach starts to go
grumbly that's why your chest starts to
get tight because you are about to do
something
that exposes you you're about to do
something that is new you're about to do
something that is scary and your body
wants to try to protect you now your
body's misreading the situation by the
way
if you want to change your life for free
check the link right there below me and
if you want to see my mel robbins
affirmations video click the link right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy
them
continue to believe i'll see you soon